And four,
three,
two,
one.
Hello.
Hello John.
Thanks for doing this,
man.
I really appreciate it.
Oh,
this is exciting.
I don't think I've ever had a conversation as long as we're about to.
I've been listening to the happiness hypothesis over the last few days and I
really,
really enjoy it.
I'm really enjoying it.
It's really fascinating stuff,
man.
Um,
but one thing I wanted to talk about because we were talking about it right
before we got started was what's happening with Peter [inaudible] at Portland
State University.
For folks who don't know the story,
he and,
um,
I forget his two colleagues,
uh,
Challenge Bros and James Lindsey.
Yeah.
They released these fake papers,
um,
on,
uh,
like Homo eroticism and rape culture and dog parks and just really proposed your
stuff,
papers that almost like an article from the onion.
And some of them,
not only did they get peer reviewed and accepted into these journals,
but they got loud it as being these amazing places of one did one guy
and now he's getting in trouble.
That's right.
Yeah.
And,
um,
we were just talking about it and I just would love to know your thoughts as a
professor.
Like what?
Oh,
sure.
Yeah.
So you know,
for those who don't know,
I guess most of your listeners probably do,
but,
uh,
you know,
it was called the grievance studies hoax because,
and,
and this is one of the big issues going on in the academy to help,
we'll talk about,
uh,
is,
um,
you know,
what does it take to have good scholarship?
And,
and the argument is that in some fields,
as long as you hate the right things and use the right words,
you'll get published.
And that's not scholarship,
that's activism.
And so these three,
these three people who did this hoax,
um,
they were trying to show that that's the case.
And so they wrote these papers.
One of them was actually a section of mine comp and they just substituted in
something about feminism for Nazi-ism,
something like that.
And,
um,
I don't remember that that one actually got pubmatic at it.
At any rate.
The point is they were trying to show that this is some of these fields in the
academy or not really about scholarship.
They're just about showing that you hate the right things.
They're activists.
And so,
uh,
there's no way to break in within those closed world.
So they did a time honored thing.
They did a hoax,
they published the date,
submitted these papers,
they made up fake names and,
and a lot of them got accepted.
And now what's happening is that a,
the university Portland State University,
which is only one of the three is at a,
is a,
is a professor,
he's a,
uh,
assistant professor,
so he's not tenured.
Um,
you know,
of course he has a lot of enemies.
And uh,
of course I don't know what's going on behind the scenes,
but it looks like some of them wanted him investigated for violating the Irb,
the internal review board,
because the claim is they fabricated data because one of the papers says,
I inspected the genitals of 10,000 dogs and the dog park,
you know,
it's like obviously absurd.
And he said,
you know,
in 63% of the,
of the attempted hump it,
cause the thing that I think of the article was that the idea that,
you know,
you go to a dog park and you see dogs humping each other and they were
interpreting this as rape,
as doggy rape and so
he's got all these nuts,
you know,
fake numbers in there.
So is that fraud,
is that data fraud?
And if you read,
so I'm,
I'm writing a letter for a lot of us are not writing letters in support of,
of Ian.
Thank you for doing that.
Um,
but if you read the,
they at his university committee was in paneled and they looked at the literal
definition of data fabrication and it's possible that he does fall under that.
But the point of,
of,
of this whole thing,
so it's not,
I can't weigh in on whether or not technically,
um,
but,
but these rules are put in place to prevent the corruption of the scientific
record.
And what he was doing was not going to corrupt.
The scientific record was done to correct it when you were doing it to show that
there's a huge problem and then they were going to unveil it.
So the question is,
is the university going to interpret it this in the worst possible way,
in the narrowest possible way,
and thereby make fools of themselves look like laughingstocks.
Um,
or are they going to use some common sense and recognize this for what it was?
It wasn't data fabrication.
It wasn't a fraud yet was an expo say.
That's right.
And I hope that they come to their senses and they do have a point,
if I'm going to be completely objective about data fabrication,
I mean technically,
I mean maybe they could have written that paper without saying that they
actually tested 10,000 genitals.
But what's really important,
I think,
is that they recognize that regular people are paying attention to this now.
People that aren't involved in this very insulated world and they're going,
this is crazy.
Like imagine if your children are going there and your children,
children are being taught at this school that's willing to accept this kind of
nonsense like this.
What happened at Evergreen state universities and another example of that.
It's right.
It's incredibly damaging to them as a university.
I mean their enrollment is sensitive on it down.
That's right.
Their funding is in real big trouble and they're there.
It's a real bad situation for them.
And if you talk to Bret Weinstein,
it was a wonderful place just a few years ago when he was teaching there.
That's right.
And it's gotten crazier and crazier on these campuses to the point where
nonsense is never being,
is not being questioned at all.
It's just being accepted as just some,
some it's,
it's almost like some religious dogma that you have to follow.
That's right.
So the weight,
I think the way to make sense of all of this is you have to always look at what
game is being played.
So human beings evolved in small scale societies.
We have all kinds of abilities to function in those small scale societies.
One of those is religious worship.
We're very good at making something sacred and circling around it.
Another is war.
We're very good at forming teams to fight the other side.
And we love that so much.
We create sports and you know,
video game battles with team versus team.
So there's all these different games you can play.
And the truth seeking game is a,
it was a really special one in a weird one and we're not very good at
it as individuals.
And in my view,
the genius of university is that it takes people and puts them together in ways
where each person,
each like scientists aren't the super rational creatures that are,
you know,
looking to disconfirm their own ideas.
No,
we're not looking.
We want to approve our ideas,
we love our ideas,
but a university puts us together in a way in which you are really motivated to
disprove my ideas and I'm motivated to disprove yours.
You put us together,
we cancel out each other's confirmation biases.
So the truth seeking games,
a very special game that can only be played in a very special institution with
special norms.
Okay.
So we're doing this for my whole time in academia.
I started Grad School in 1987 at the University of Pennsylvania.
And then just in the last few years,
it's like some people are playing this really different game and it's like,
if,
you know,
if I'm playing tennis and I hit the ball to you,
like we're in a seminar class,
I give you a question,
I challenge challenging you come back.
And we go back and forth and in the process we learn.
So that's like kind of like playing tennis.
So I'm doing this and then suddenly like someone tackles me like,
what?
That you don't do that in tennis?
No,
no,
but they're playing football.
You see,
and in football it's a much rougher game and you're trying to destroy the
others.
I mean,
not really in football,
but I'm saying it's,
you know,
it's,
um,
and so as norms of combat come in,
and what I mean by that is political combat as some people within universities
see that what we're doing here is not seeking truth.
We're trying to fight fascism or we're trying to defeat conservatism or we're
trying to fight racism or whatever.
Some sort of a political goal.
And these games are completely incompatible.
And so that's why this madness has erupted where you see professors saying
something,
maybe it's a little provocative.
I mean going back to Socrates,
that was kind of the point was to provoke,
um,
and you see these bizarre reactions,
emotional reactions,
uh,
groups organize to demand that a professor be fired because we're playing
different games.
Yeah.
How did this start?
How did it start?
Um,
cause it seems like there,
there has to be an event or something or,
yeah,
the trend.
Well,
so,
so the,
you know,
the book that a,
I'm the book that I just put out in September,
uh,
with Greg Lukey on off the coddling of the American mind.
Um,
I read the first chapter of that as well.
Okay.
Well thank you for admitting that it was only one chapter.
Usually I'll delve into that one because,
uh,
unfortunately,
I was,
I was reading that and then I got on a flight and I just wanted to zone out.
So listen to this one on tape.
Okay.
All right.
Well I'll tell you all about it.
But the key thing is that that book,
the calling the American mind was something that we wrote because Greg began
observing this weird stuff happening in universities in 2014.
It all starts in 2014.
Um,
most of your listeners have heard about safe spaces,
microaggressions,
bias,
response teams,
trigger warnings,
all that stuff.
That stuff didn't exist before 2014.
It just begins creeping in then.
And then it kind of blows up in 2015.
And so our whole book is an explanation of why,
why did this happen?
And so to your question about was there an event,
our answer is there are six different causal threads.
There's like all these social trends,
some going back to the eighties and nineties that came together around 2014 so
that students are a little different.
And then there are certain forces acting on them that are different.
And so you get this weird new game,
you get this explosive mix.
You get some students who are actually very drawn to grievance studies.
Uh,
and so,
um,
very briefly like the,
it's things like,
um,
rising political polarization.
So left and right.
Never particularly liked each other,
but in the seventies and eighties,
if you look at surveys done of how much you hate people,
the other side,
it's not that intense.
It begins going up in the,
in the 80s,
and then especially after 2000,
it's going up very steeply.
Uh,
at the same time,
university faculty who've always leaned left throughout the 20th century,
uh,
but it was only a lien and in the 90s,
it begins shifting much further left so that now faculties,
especially in the social sciences and humanities are pretty purified.
They're overwhelmingly on the left,
so you have a more left leaning a university at a time when left,
right.
Hostility is getting more and more intense.
And so any question that has a political valence,
now there's a lot more people who want to do the football game,
not the truth seeking,
but then we got to defeat the other side.
Don't give me nuance,
don't give me data.
We know what we believe and dammit,
we're going to,
you know,
so she had got this it changing political situation and then you've got a couple
of threads about what we've done to kids.
So,
um,
uh,
and to have,
God,
this is a whole nother area conversation for us,
but we basically took away free play and gave them social media the same
basically kids who were born in 1995 and after Gen z they had really different
childhoods and they're not as prepared for conflict and college and we'll get
into that later.
But you put all these things together,
you get kids who are much more anxious and fragile,
much more depressed,
um,
coming on to campus at a time of much greater political activism.
And now these grievance studies ideas about America is a matrix of oppression
and look at the world in terms of good versus evil.
It's more appealing to them.
And it's that minority of students.
They're the ones who are initiating a lot of the movements.
It's such a strange time to be on the outside and watched this because a person
like myself is always counted on intellectuals and professors and people like
yourself to sort of make sense of things and to reinforce the idea that freedom
of speech and free debate are critical aspects to knowledge.
And one of the things that's most disturbing you see in schools is people that
are even marginally right leaning or centrist being called Nazis being silenced
and they're pulling fire alarms when they're speaking.
And even people like Christina Hoff summers who's a feminist gets shouted down
and,
and people yelling at her and calling her a fascist.
It's just very strange.
It's very strange to watch from the outside.
And it's also very strange to not see any pushback by the professors.
So sitting here and seeing this happen and thinking,
well,
these poor kids,
they're,
they're going to have to go into the workplace.
They're going to have to,
they're there right now.
They're in this very insulated environment.
They're going to escape that environment when they graduate.
And then they're either going to push this ideology into the workforce,
which you do see now,
especially with 10 classmates.
Yeah,
that's right now.
That's right.
I know it's strange to look at it from the outside and believe me,
it's stranger from the inside.
But one thing I can say that,
um,
that might be helpful here is that from the outside,
what you see is the news reports and the news reports are going to be very
selective.
And so especially what happens is because you know,
universities have always leaned left and so the right leaning media have always
been suspicious.
So the right leaning media has huge coverage of every little thing.
And sometimes it's,
it's exaggerated.
Sometimes it's misinterpreted the most time there was something there,
left leaning media tends to ignore it.
And so I go around the country and you know,
people in the right expect that,
oh my God,
it's chaos and mob violence on campus,
which isn't true.
That's an exaggeration.
And the left is like,
problem,
what problem?
There's nothing changing.
Um,
and so I think the key thing to keep in mind here is that there's about 4,500
institutions of higher education in this country.
Most of them are not selective schools.
They'll take anyone who comes,
um,
and in those schools,
not much is happening.
Um,
but if you go to the elite liberal arts colleges in the northeast and the west
coast,
then usually something is happening.
And so,
uh,
at Heterodox Academy,
it's a group that I cofounded of professors that are pushing back.
It's bipartisan.
We have as many people on the,
on the left is on the right.
Um,
we created a map of where all the shutdowns have taken place and they're all
right in the northeast or along the Pacific coast,
like from,
you know,
evergreen,
down to Berkeley and all that.
Uh,
and then a couple in Chicago.
So from,
in most of the country,
this stuff is not happening.
In most schools,
the culture hasn't really changed much,
but at the top schools in general,
it has.
Um,
so that's one thing to just keep in mind.
There is a moral panic on the right about this,
which doesn't mean that there's not something real,
there really is a huge problem,
but it's not as pervasive as it sometimes made out to be.
So is it akin to looking at violence in the news media like you,
your,
when you read about violence in terms of robberies and murders in general,
you're not going to encounter much in your life.
The world is a large place,
but we concentrate on these really bad moments.
Yeah,
it's a little bit like that except that,
um,
you know,
one of the reasons that we took child,
we took free play away from kids is that we were afraid that they'd be abducted
and that almost never,
and that was so rare.
Uh,
and,
but we got a lot of coverage of that in the eighties and nineties
and we change our behavior because of that.
And that was a gross overreaction.
The situation on campuses is not like that.
It's,
it's your odds of being nailed are much higher than that.
Um,
and so,
you know,
I hear every day,
or at least every week I get an email from a professor who says,
you know,
I,
I used a metaphor in class and somebody reported me.
And like,
you know,
and so once this happens to you,
you,
you pull back,
you change your teaching style.
What we're seeing on campus is a spectacular collapse of trust between students
and professors.
And when we don't trust each other,
we can't do,
we can't do our job.
We can't,
we can't risk provoking being provocative,
raising new ideas,
raising uncomfortable ideas.
We have to play it safe.
And then everybody suffers.
Is social media partially to blame because it's huge.
Social media's a huge part of this problem.
So,
um,
uh,
in a couple ways.
So one is the generational thing that we have,
um,
kids born after 1995 got this in middle school.
It had a variety of effects on them.
So kids coming in are more conversant with call out culture.
And so that's a big part of this.
Um,
the other thing though is that we used to have what you would call a reasonable
person standard.
So,
uh,
you know,
so,
um,
you know,
for professor,
uh,
what's one,
so professor just wrote to me recently,
he said he,
you know,
he got frustrated while trying to explain something and he said,
oh,
shoot me now.
Um,
and student was offended by this because are you making fun of people committing
suicide and okay,
you know,
add,
she come to him and said,
you know,
professor,
I know you didn't mean anything,
but that was kind of insensitive.
Okay,
that would have been great.
Like that's the way to handle it.
But for this generation raised with call out culture and social media,
you almost never hear of a student coming to someone else in private because you
don't get credit for that.
So you only get credit when you call them out publicly.
And so that's why we're all walking on egg shells because most of our students
are great.
Most of them are fine.
But if I have a class of 300 students,
a lecture class,
I know that some of them subscribe to this new call out culture safety as a
morality.
And so if I say one thing,
it's not a reasonable person standard.
It's a most sensitive person standard.
I have to teach to the most sensitive person in the class.
It's also that person has the opportunity to score right there.
Exactly.
Throw up that virtue flag.
Like I've got one on the board here.
Look what I did.
I nailed the professor on saying shoot me now and now I'm a hero and exited this
a safer space for everybody else that that's right.
And so and so that's really what is messing us up at so many levels of society
and the fact that a lot of these problems,
the difficulties of democracy,
the rise of authoritarian populism,
that there,
there are a lot of weird trends that are happening in multiple countries and I
think it's the rise of of devices and social media is the main way we can
explain why it's so similar across countries.
Do you think that this is us?
Is this some sort of a trend that will eventually correct itself when these kids
get out into the real world and then go through a whole generation of that and
then people realize the error of their ways and the disastrous results of having
these unprepared or emotionally unprepared kids?
No,
I'm not confident that it will not correct itself.
I think that once we understand it,
I think they were writing things we can do to change it.
But here's the way to understand it and why it's not going to change itself.
So,
so I'm a,
I'm a social psychologist,
is my main,
my main area.
Um,
but I,
I love all of the social sciences.
I love thinking about complex systems and systems composed of people are really
different from systems composed of stars or neutrons or anything else.
And so if you have a complex system composed of people,
these people are primarily working to increase their prestige.
So,
I mean,
once we have our needs for,
you know,
food and things like that are set,
we're,
we're always interacting in ways to make ourselves look good.
Uh,
and to protect ourselves from being nailed or accused of something.
So we're always doing reputation management.
Now.
Um,
think about in any group,
what gives you prestige.
And so if you look in a group of teenagers,
you might have a group,
uh,
in which it's athletics.
And so if that's how you get prestige,
then all the kids are going to be working out and training and practicing.
And that doesn't hurt anybody.
That doesn't impose an external cost on anyone else.
But you can have some really sick prestige economies.
Uh,
and so there's a,
there's an ethnography about a fill a,
I'm an indigenous population in the Philippines,
uh,
by Shelly resolve though was the anthropologist,
I think it's called knowledge and passion about the along good,
which is a name for a,
a tribe in the Philippines.
And in this tribe,
it's a headhunting tribe.
They find people and cut off their heads,
not just for fun,
for prestige.
So in a lot of societies,
um,
you have a lot of male initiation.
Boys have to do something to become a man.
And if the thing you have to do to become a man is you have to cut off someone's
head.
Okay?
So that imposes rather a heavy cost on outsiders.
All right?
So this is a sick culture.
This is not one where we can say,
oh well that's just the way they do things.
Okay,
this has to stop.
Um,
and ideally they would cut off a stranger's head.
Like they find someone from another tribe or someone you know,
from a government agency,
they're just cut off his head.
Um,
uh,
but if necessary,
if there's a fight or if there's somebody within their larger community that can
also get you points.
So this is a really sick culture.
Now head call it culture is not quite that bad,
but it's the same logic.
Okay?
So if you have a group of teenagers or college students who are all struggling
for prestige as we all are,
and if you get a sub culture in which the way you get prestige is by calling
someone out,
showing that they're racist,
sexist,
homophobic,
transphobic,
Islamophobic,
whatever it is.
If you can catch them,
you get the points.
What you're doing here is your imposing an external cost,
others.
And that's what makes you so insufferable because you are playing your game.
But I'm paying the cost of your game.
And so that,
I think it's hard to,
people aren't going to break out of that themselves.
But once we understand what's happening,
I think in a sense we can all come together and call out,
call out culture and say,
stop,
stop imposing these costs on us.
But how are we going to reach those kids if professors are so terrified to speak
out and to cause controversy in class and no one wants to criticize them?
Because if you do,
you risk your job,
you risk them organizing against you.
It
the shift.
So the,
so I'm hopeful that we can shift it because most people hate it.
So even the people who do it recognize that they're always on eggshells.
They can be next.
Um,
there's the tendency of people in this culture to,
you know,
as we say,
they eat their own.
They eventually turn on each other.
Um,
and the mental health costs of it.
I mean,
there are a number of essays that have been written by people who sort of left
that.
And it sounds miserable to be inside that you're always your,
you know,
there's no humor,
there's no fun.
It's always,
you know,
hyper serious,
angry.
Um,
and so,
um,
so I think that,
I think if we can,
uh,
if we can raise kids or encourage them to see the games that social media makes
them do and give them a vocabulary,
I don't know what we should come up with some catchy terms for it,
but give them a vocabulary so that they can,
they cannot be like,
oh,
you're,
you know,
you're a calling out,
or I don't know,
that's a clunky,
but we can help them label this behavior as mocket.
Exactly.
There's patterns that you see in,
in people that
from a distance,
like a,
if I look at it,
when I look at them objectively,
there's like these,
these patents,
I go,
oh,
that's one of those Mager guys.
He's one of those,
uh,
you know,
he's got an American flag with an eagle and his avatar on Twitter rant.
If you go through his page,
it's all like talking great about POTUS and criticizing anyone.
It talks about about trumpets.
It's strange.
It's like these patterns of behavior,
these predetermined pattern,
there are stereotypes,
not just stereotypes like they've fallen into a well oiled slick groove that's
very easy to predict.
If you are one of those people,
it's,
it's super easy to predict that you're going to be pro second amendment.
It's super easy to predict that you're probably going to be skeptical about
climate change.
There's all these different things that go along with these patterns of behavior
and you see them on the right.
You see him on the left and the it's,
it's weird to watch.
It's weird to watch on the outside is like,
well,
this is such an,
an easy pattern to slip into.
Yeah.
Well that's right.
Um,
so,
uh,
there's data from the Pew surveys.
They've been measuring attitudes of Americans since the eighties or nineties,
uh,
but they've been publishing this series on polarization in which they show that
in the 90s,
if you knew somebody that attitude on,
say,
gun control,
that would only predict their attitude on abortion a certain percent.
And a lot of people on the left,
let's say,
would hold six of the 10 leftist attitudes and same on the right.
But gradually by the time you get to around 2010,
it's like if you know one attitude,
you know them all.
And that's in part just because if you turn up the volume.
So we evolve to do us versus them.
And the more we see,
you know,
if it's us,
America versus them communist Russia or Nazi Germany,
what then,
you know,
then we all come together.
And that's great for social cohesion and trust.
Um,
but as that fades away and as us versus them became increasingly left versus
right,
and as we lost the liberal Republicans and the conservative Democrats,
those used to exist until the eighties or nineties,
um,
as we lost them once it becomes us versus them is left versus right now,
if you only hold your team's position on six out of 10 items,
you're a trader.
And so you better get with the program.
And so the pressures for conformity,
the pressures to agree with your team on everything had been steadily rising.
And that means there's no nuance and we can't do higher education without
nuance.
We can't do college without free thinking and the ability to say,
well,
you know what,
wait a second.
Maybe they do have a point on this,
on this thing.
And that's one of the reasons why it looks so weird from the outside and why
it's getting so unpleasant from the inside
when you're teaching classes and a subject comes up that may be controversial.
Do you,
do you have like this overwhelming feeling that you're treading on dangerous
ground?
Yeah.
So,
um,
I,
I taught psych one on one at the University of Virginia and I would do all,
I would take them into,
you know,
sex differences,
origin of sex,
sexual orientation.
I would even do race differences.
Um,
and Eh,
you know,
because there was a reasonable person standard and I trusted my students and
they trusted me and we had a great time and we covered a lot,
a lot of stuff.
Um,
but now and then I moved to New York University in 2011.
uh,
when my last previous book,
the righteous mind came out.
And it's not a,
it's not about Uva versus Nyu is just about the changing time.
Um,
now as I said,
I have to teach to the most sensitive students.
So I teach a course on business ethics,
on professional responsibility,
and we have a section on,
um,
uh,
on discrimination and employment law.
It's important to cover it.
We have to cover it,
you know,
Mba students have to know where the lines are,
what the lawyers.
Um,
and yeah,
I'm kind of scared when I teach that.
Uh,
because you know,
I'd like to get into all sorts of things.
Um,
I'd like to get into,
well,
you know,
what to numerical disparities mean if there's a gender difference in,
in the percentage of tech,
but not in the percentage of non tech employees in Silicon Valley.
Well what does that mean?
I would like to talk about that.
But if a single student thinks that I am denying the existence of sexism,
they could be offended by that.
And in every bathroom at Nyu,
there's a sign telling them how to report me anonymously and they put these up
in 2016 in response to student requests.
Um,
and that means that all professors are on notice that they can be reported
anonymously at any moment.
But children,
well,
these are,
uh,
I'm not going to call them children.
I mean my students are Mba students,
but uh,
but the undergrads,
1717 to 21 year olds for the undergrads.
Yes,
that's right.
Barely not children anymore.
That's right.
And there's an incentive to this,
this what we're talking about before.
There's this incentive that gives them attention.
They get prestige.
They get value from it.
And this,
that this culture encourages these things.
That's right.
And this is a terrible lesson to teach them.
Um,
so,
you know,
the subtitle of our book,
it's called the coddling,
the American mind,
how good intentions and bad ideas are setting up a generation for failure.
And so these microaggression reporting system,
that's basically what it is.
Um,
a microaggression reporting system.
It has a good intention behind it.
Um,
there are cases of professors who make ethnic jokes.
Okay.
They should stop doing that.
I mean,
maybe that was okay 30 years ago.
You know,
there are,
there,
there are legitimate complaints and faculty do,
there should be some accountability,
some responsibility.
So there's a good intention behind it,
but it's usually based on no empirical evidence.
And because it's based on pressure applied to a bureaucracy,
not by a committee thinking,
hmm,
how can we improve the climate for everyone?
No,
no.
It's like we make these demands and we demand 10 things and the administration
says,
okay,
we'll give you five of them.
Um,
um,
there's not thought put into what would happen if we give the students in East
German style anonymous reporting system.
And so everybody's on notice that they can be reported any point what might
happen to the social dynamics,
like nobody thought that through.
So the net,
the net effect again,
is the spectacular collapse of trust on campus to be in the middle of that.
It's gotta be so bizarre having taught for so many years before that and to
watch almost like this virus overtake the institutions,
that's what it felt like.
Um,
and that's why,
so,
you know,
Greg [inaudible] came to me in 2014 so Greg,
I'll just touch briefly tell this story of the book.
Um,
Greg is the president of the foundation for individual rights in education.
he fired and they defend free speech rights on campus and they were always
pushing back against administrators who would say,
Oh,
you know,
we need a free speech zone.
And they're always afraid of liability.
And so,
but suddenly,
suddenly in 2014,
Greg start seeing students pushing back on,
on speech rate saying,
we want,
you know,
Bam,
that speaker,
you know,
uh,
we need,
you know,
a safe space if their debate is going to be held.
Uh,
new stuff,
weird stuff.
And Greg,
who is prone to depression,
um,
he had a suicidal depression in 2007.
He's hospitalized when he gets out of the hospital.
He learns CBT,
cognitive behavioral therapy.
And in that you learn these like 15 or so cognitive distortions like
catastrophizing.
Um,
I'm overgeneralizing black and white thinking.
So Greg learns to not do those himself.
And then he goes back to record fire.
And then in 2014 he sees students saying,
Oh,
if,
you know,
if Christina Hoff summers comes to campus,
people will die or there'll be,
you know,
people will be harmed,
injured.
Um,
and so there's this,
uh,
this new way of thinking and Greg thinks,
wow,
how are students learning to do this?
Like are,
are we teaching them on campus to think in these distorted ways?
And if we are,
isn't that going to make them depressed?
So Greg comes to talk to me in May of 2014 to tell me this idea and I think it's
really brilliant.
I think it's a great idea cause I'd be going to see this,
you know,
the safe spaces that microaggression is,
the trigger warning requests.
Um,
so we,
we wrote up our,
our essay,
uh,
submitted to the Atlantic.
It came out in August of 2015 and it was like we were just seeing the first
outbreaks of a,
of a virus.
And then in the fall of 2015,
it's,
it becomes an epidemic.
And so many of your listeners will have heard of or seen the videos of what
happened at Yale,
um,
in,
uh,
November,
2015 when Erika Christakis wrote an email saying,
now wait a second.
Yale is telling you how to do your Halloween costumes.
Maybe we should think this through ourselves.
Maybe you're old enough to make your own decisions.
Some students get very upset.
They protest,
they bring demands to the president.
They are screaming at her husband.
Uh,
so it was then when that protest was successful,
when the president of Yale basically said,
you know,
we,
we're wrong.
You're right.
We validate your narrative will give you as much as we can have your demands.
Um,
when,
when that happened,
then the protest went national.
And so throughout 2016,
you have,
um,
you have groups of students making these demands,
demanding microaggression reporting systems.
So that's when Nyu put in its systems,
it's microaggression reporting systems.
So that Yale event wasn't just an isolated incident.
It really was the spark.
I think so.
Yeah.
So there's all these tree threads coming together.
It didn't come out of nowhere.
All these things are happening.
It's almost like the,
you know,
the whole,
the whole room is like almost at combustion temperature.
And then Yale was the spark that sent a national,
what's crazy about Yale is anybody that's objective that's watching from the
outside.
It's like these students are out of control.
They're screaming at this professor like,
this is supposed to be a safe place and you know,
you fucked this up.
And they're,
they're,
they're being incredibly hostile and aggressive towards him.
And surrounding him.
And when you,
when you watch that from the outside you think,
well obviously they've got to punish these,
these students.
I mean I didn't know they did the opposite.
Yeah,
that's right.
The Mans that's well,
well it doesn't make sense from the outside,
but again,
you have to look at different games being played.
So,
um,
so I went to Yale.
I graduated from there in 1985.
I loved it.
I was in Davenport College is one of the 12 residential colleges and there were
a lot of intellectual events that would happen in the colleges.
Like the master of the college or the dean of the college would bring in all
kinds of people to speak.
So they were intellectual spaces as well as sort of home like,
or not exactly home,
like,
like transitional places where they were,
they were places that you lived.
So the yield that I knew was a place that taught me to think in lots of
different ways and it just was constantly blowing my mind.
Like my took my first economics course.
It was like,
wow,
here's a new pair of spectacles that I can put on.
And suddenly I see all these,
you know,
prices and supply.
And like I never,
I never learned to think that way where I learned about Freud in psychology or
sociology.
So a good education is one that lets you look at our complicated world through
multiple perspectives and that makes you smart.
That's what a liberal arts education should do.
But what I see increasingly happening,
especially at elite schools,
is the dominance of a single story.
And that single story is life is a battle between good people and evil people or
rather good groups and evil groups.
Um,
and,
uh,
it's a zero sum game.
And so if the bad groups have more,
it's because they took it from the,
the good groups.
And so the point of everything is to fight the bad groups,
bring them down,
create a quality.
Um,
and this is a terrible way to think in a free society.
I mean,
that might have worked,
you know,
in Biblical days when you got the mower bites to killing the Jebusites or
whatever.
Um,
but you know,
we,
we live in an era in which we've discovered that that the pie can be grown a
million fold.
And so to teach students to see society as a zero sum competition between groups
is primitive and destructive.
Now in your book,
you,
you actually identify the moment where these microaggressions sort of made their
appearance and they were initially a racist thing.
So yeah,
so the idea of a microaggression,
it goes back to,
um,
I forget the,
it's an African American sociologist in the seventies first coined the term,
but it really becomes popular in a 2007 article,
uh,
by Derald wing sue at teachers college.
And so he talks about this concept of microaggressions.
And there are two things that are good about the concert that are useful.
And so one is as racism as explicit racism has clearly gone down by any measure,
explicit racism has plummeted in American across the West.
Um,
but you know,
there could still be subtle or veiled a racist claims.
So perfectly legitimate.
I want to find the difference between explicit racism.
Well,
explicit racism.
It is,
you know,
calling someone a racial slur.
I hate you because x,
um,
they're identified because of they've been reported as crimes or,
well,
I would just say that,
um,
if you are a member of a culture,
you can tell when someone is saying something to insult,
to put down or to express hostility and that's something that judgment we can
make.
And as that's become socially unacceptable in most circles,
so explicit racism is way,
way down.
Right.
But how,
I'm sorry,
but the,
my only question is how are they measuring us?
Um,
that,
well,
how do you measure microaggression?
How do you measure even explicit racism?
How do you say it's down?
Um,
certainly attitude measures.
So there,
so surveys done in private.
How would you feel if a,
if a black family moved in next door,
if a Filipino family moved now?
So how would you feel if your child married a,
you know,
a Jew,
a Muslim?
So explicit surveys show it.
Um,
certainly,
um,
I mean if,
if,
when you do surveys of people's experience,
people have of race of every race when they report,
how often this happens to me every year the numbers are actually fairly low.
So,
uh,
there are ways of measuring experiences of racism,
right?
How accurate are these?
Cause they're like,
first you start with a joke about this,
but the idea of the problem services,
you're only getting information from people.
So stupid.
They take surveys like who's taking servers?
So some surveys are subject to that.
But in general,
if you,
if you approach a question from multiple perspectives and say in one condition,
you pay them for an accurate answer or not.
When my condition they're anonymous or they're not.
Um,
so you can get a sense of how much the answer moves around depending on external
conditions.
Um,
and so anyway,
the point I just wanted to make is that the acceptability of using the n word or
other things,
you know,
if a bunch of white people are talking,
the acceptibility using the n word,
I think has gone way down in general.
Would you agree with that?
Yes.
Yes,
tremendously.
I mean,
I,
I agree with the sentiment and I agree with the,
um,
the trend that there is absolutely a trend,
uh,
away from racism.
But I was just curious as how they measured it.
Yeah.
I'm not an expert in that area,
so I'm assuming it's surveys and analysis of discourse ultimately for everyone's
sake.
I mean,
even for the sake of the people that are embroiled in all this controversy in
chaos,
it would be fantastic across the board if there was no more sexism,
there was no more racism,
there was no more,
any of these things me would be wonderful.
Then we could just start treating puments as just humans.
Like this is just who you are.
You're just a person.
No one cares.
That would be what a wonderful world we would live in.
If this was no longer an issue at all.
Beautifully put it.
How does that get,
how does that ever get through?
So we were getting there again,
that's what the 20,
I mean that's what the 20th century was about.
So you and I are shaped by,
I don't know how old you are,
but I'm the fun one.
Okay.
I'm 55.
Um,
we were shaped by the late 20th century and the late 20th century was a time in
America in which,
you know,
earlier on there was all kinds of prejudice.
I mean,
when I was,
so when I was born,
just right before you were born,
it was legal to say you can't eat here because you're black.
And so,
you know,
that changed in 1964 65.
Um,
but,
um,
it used to be that we had legal differentiations by race and then those
were knocked down,
but we still had social.
And it used to be that if you were gay,
there was something humiliating.
It had to be hidden.
And you,
you know,
I mean,
so if you look at where we were in 1960 or 63 when I was born,
and then you look at where we got by 2000,
I mean,
the progress is fantastic on every front.
So that's all.
I mean when I say we were moving in that direction and to your point about,
you know,
wouldn't it be great if there was none of this?
We just treat people like people.
Okay.
Yeah.
That was the 20th century idea is let's,
let's get past these tribal identifications and what is so alarming to me now is
that on campus it began on campus but it's spreading elsewhere there and against
not everywhere on campus.
It's mostly in the grievance studies departments,
they're teaching students the opposite.
They're teaching students don't treat everyone like a person.
People are their identities and you can tell somebody's identity is by looking
at people and so you know if they're good or bad.
This I think is the opposite of progress.
Well it's,
it's also the differences between us are really fascinating.
The differences between men and women I think are some of the more interesting
explanations for human behavior and it,
and I'm not meaning that people must be defined by their gender are defined by
their sacks.
And,
but it is interesting when you look at these gigantic groups,
like why certain people tend to gravitate towards certain occupations or certain
types of behavior or certain hobbies.
It is really fascinating.
Yeah,
that's right.
And if we were playing the truth seeking game,
if all we cared about is trying to understand things,
we would do the research and we'd figure out what to people like in a,
and do lefthanders versus right handers have different preferences?
Probably not as far as I know.
Do Boys and girls have different preferences?
Yeah,
they're really big.
Uh,
do men and women have different,
do they enjoy different things?
Yeah.
Um,
so we could take that and we could say our goal is to create a free society.
This is,
this is what the word liberal traditionally meant.
A society which people are free to construct a life that they want to live.
And so if you're born one race or another,
that should not in any way be a limitation.
And in the 20th century we made a lot of progress towards that ideal,
same painful
saying we did.
Meaning that you,
you're implying that it ended but the progress hit a wall.
Um,
yeah,
I shouldn't imply that because overall I think the trends are unstoppable.
Right.
So I don't want to say that things are working.
Yeah,
I agree.
But you feel like there is a slow down or
which,
yeah,
I think that,
so,
um,
so in chapter three of the coddling,
Greg and I look at identity politics and one thing we really try to do is
there's all these loaded terms and you know,
if somebody says social justice warrior,
okay,
you know a lot about them.
If they said that,
like they're going to come at it and say,
oh,
those SJWs and we don't do any of that.
We,
we say,
um,
there are people on campus who are very focused on identity issues and on
injustices based on identity.
And that's great.
And there's a lot to be concerned about.
And their right to do that.
Now how do they do it?
And there's two different ways you can either do what we call common enemy
identity politics,
which is where you say life is a battle between good grips and evil groups.
Let's divide people by,
you know,
by race.
So it's basically the straight versus everyone else.
Men versus all the other genders,
um,
and a white versus everybody else.
And so you look at,
you know,
the straight white men,
they're the problem.
All the other groups must unite to fight the straight white man.
So that's one of the core ideas of intersectionality.
And so we say in the book is that leads to eternal conflict.
Much better is to,
is an identity politics based on common humanity.
So we don't say,
Oh to hell with that entity politics.
We say you have to have identity politics until you have perfect justice and
equality.
You have to have a way for groups to organize,
to push back on things,
to demand Jess,
that's fine.
But if you do it by first emphasizing common humanity,
that's what Martin Luther King did.
That's what Pauli Murray did.
That's what Nelson Mandela did.
This wonderful woman,
Pauli Murray,
she was a gay black,
um,
possibly trans,
civil rights leader in beginning of the forties.
She says,
when my,
uh,
you know,
when my opponents draw a small circle to exclude me,
I shoulder a larger circle to include them.
I shall shout for the rights of all mankind.
And this is again,
when Martin Luther King did,
he's relentlessly appealing to our white brothers and sisters.
He's using the language of America of Christianity.
Start by saying what we have in common and then people's hearts are open.
Where within a community now we can talk about our difficulties.
So it's the rise of common enemy identity politics on campus,
in the grievance studies departments especially that I think is an alarming
trend.
Another thing that's alarming to me is the redefining of terms like sexism and
racism or sexism against men as impossible.
Racism against White People's impossible,
right?
This redefining as these prejudices only exist if you're coming from a position
of power that's really weird.
And it also,
it opens up the door to treating people as an other,
literally the people that are the victims of racism are now using racism against
other people and feeling justified because of it and it,
and having a bunch of people that will agree with them that this is in fact not
racism.
And this is pushing back on white privilege and saying all these different weird
things that,
you know,
and,
and they feel really comfortable in saying these open,
racist,
generalizing things about white people or about white men or about,
you know,
fill in the blank.
But whatever group that you're a,
you're attacking.
And it's,
it's really strange.
It's really strange to see.
But again,
it makes sense if you look at the different games.
Yeah.
So if you're on university and you think you're playing the truth game and
philosophers are great at this,
they're always unpacking terms.
And so you might try to define racism of our,
or any sort of ism and you a common sense view.
It would be an expression of hostility or resentment or limitation on a group
based on their identity.
Um,
but that's if you're playing the truth seeking game,
if you're playing the politics game or the warfare game,
um,
you want to define the terms to give your side maximum advantage.
So there's a wonderful social psychologist named Phil Tetlock at Penn,
at Wharton,
and he talks about these different mindsets we get into.
And one of them,
he calls the intuitive prosecutor.
So if,
if I'm,
if my goal as a scholar is to prosecute my enemies and maximally convict them,
and I am always trying to defend,
you know,
seven different identity groups against the straight white men,
they're the,
they're the accused.
I want to define my terms to make it maximally easy to convict.
And so I am going to say racism and microaggressions.
It doesn't matter what the intent was,
all that matters is the impact.
All that matters about the person felt that way.
As long as someone's offended,
I get to charge you with a crime.
So,
uh,
and also on racism,
um,
you can say as,
as you know,
a lot of kids are learning in high school that these days racism is prejudice
plus power.
So by definition,
a black person or a gay person or whatever,
any,
you know,
cannot be racist or whatever other term because they don't have power regardless
of their social class being taught.
Yeah.
So their professors are,
this is kind of their mouth.
This is taught in a number of high schools.
Uh,
at my nephews went to Andover.
they learned this offensive thing.
Yes.
It's deep defensive children.
It's not just that it's offensive and obviously hypocritical.
It's that it's crippling.
Yes.
I mean,
can you imagine,
can you,
so look,
you've,
you've got kids,
right?
You have two,
two daughters,
right?
Because you have three daughters.
Can you imagine giving your daughter's a cloak of invulnerability where you say
you put this on,
now you get to attack others,
but no one can touch you.
Like this is going to warp their development,
power corrupts and even moral or rhetorical power corrupts as well.
How is this being taught though?
I mean,
how,
how is this because this different houses except as a part of a curriculum.
So because the goal is not truth,
the goal is victory over racism,
let's say.
And so if that's the case,
you're going to focus on educating kids about their white privilege and um,
making end.
So that's what a lot of these privilege exercises are.
You know,
you line kids up by their privilege and you and your,
your goal is to make the straight white boys feel bad about their privilege and
therefore talk less,
take up less space,
their privilege.
This is what we were talking about earlier about the goal is no racism.
The privilege only exists if there's racism.
Like instead of concentrating on the privilege,
it only exists if people do preferentially treat certain preferential towards
certain races.
If that doesn't exist at all,
then white privilege doesn't exist.
I'm actually,
I'm not sure I'd agree with you on that.
So we also,
well,
so we had a funny episode last night and so my wife and I were out in La.
We were invited to the Golden Globes by,
by a friend.
And so we're here in la.
So we,
we,
um,
uh,
we go to bed in the hotel room and at two in the morning,
the guys pounding on the door saying,
come on,
let me in.
It's me,
it's me.
And you know,
I wake up and I go to the door and I,
and I say,
wrong room and he can't hear me.
So I opened the door a crack and just show him,
you know,
like,
look,
I don't know,
I don't know who you are and you know,
some drunk,
some drunk guy.
And uh,
and I said,
you know,
you've got the wrong room.
And I went back to bed and breakfast this morning.
My wife says,
why did you open the door?
Like,
how could you have done that?
I said,
you know,
we're in a nice hotel.
I mean,
what's,
you know,
what's gonna Happen?
And she made it clear like a woman would never have done that.
Like he was like,
you as a man,
you have the ability to go out in the world and engage with in a certain way
that I don't have as well.
I,
that's a great example.
So there is a kind of male privilege.
Sure exists.
Even if there's no sexism.
Yeah,
that's an interesting,
that's an interesting example.
Um,
that's a,
that's a sexism one,
but that's also a physical danger one.
Yeah,
that's it.
There's a,
there is a difference between just the way women have to go out into the world
being vulnerable and also being the target of,
of just a male sexual attention.
It's a very different thing.
It's an aggressive person.
Dangerous thing.
Yeah.
But I,
I think you could say the same thing about race in this way.
So,
um,
cause there's racism though.
Well,
okay.
Okay.
You're right.
If,
if there was absolute zero racism,
right.
Anywhere,
but we're never going to get to that.
But,
but the thing that we're worried about is the racism.
So like if you worried about if someone's,
if you say you have white privilege,
well that only exists if you're being dealt with in a racist manner.
So if you're a black person and there is racism that's being directed towards
you and it's not being direct towards me,
then you can say,
well,
I have white privilege.
But if there's no racism directed towards anybody,
that doesn't exist anymore.
But the kitchen was racism.
Yes.
Right.
Okay.
But so look,
I think it's,
it's helpful to always try to look at it from the other person's point of view
and to listen to their arguments and stuff.
For example,
when you and I go into any social encounter,
it never occurs to me that something,
you know,
something's gonna come up and someone's going to call me a Kike,
let's say,
you know,
cause I'm,
I'm Jewish and it just,
it just never crosses my mind that someone's going to humiliate me because I'm
Jewish.
Um,
um,
but if you're black,
even if you're in a very tolerant society,
at some point someone is going to make an assumption,
it might not be fast.
It might be.
So all I'm saying is you and I don't,
there are certain things we don't have to think about and that whereas if we
were black or other identities or visibly gay or you know,
there would be the risk of spoiling of a social interaction.
So I'm totally comfortable saying we should be telling our kids about this.
But what follows from it?
What follows from it?
Should we therefore be telling kids?
Okay,
so you know,
um,
you know,
judge people based on their appearance,
um,
be suspicious of people based on their race and gender.
That's where,
that's where I get off the bus,
the bus.
That's where I say,
now we're really hurting kids.
We should be turning down the moralism and we're turning it up.
Right.
But what I'm getting at is pointing at someone and saying,
you have white privilege.
If they are not racist,
you're,
you're giving this person,
you're putting these PR,
this person in a category that really only exists in the face of racism where
the real problem is racism.
Yes.
Well the male female thing is a very different way.
That male privilege I think is way more slippery and wave cause it's
biologically based.
There's a creepiness to men.
And then there is as much as a nice guy as I'm sure you are,
and I try very hard to be a nice guy too.
Just kidding.
But every woman's encountered creeps.
Yes.
It's,
it's inevitable because it's,
there's a a game being played this pursuing of sexual pleasure or of,
of,
of sexual encounters.
This doesn't exist or it shouldn't exist with races.
Yeah.
The just the,
the real problem in my eyes is racism and if we could figure out a way to just
complete,
obviously it's not going to let people are flawed.
They're,
they're going to be in until there's some sort of new way that we interface with
each other that eliminates lies and deception and allows each other to
completely understand each other's feelings and appreciate them,
which may happen some day,
probably technologically driven till that happens.
There's going to be a certain amount of it,
but the real enemy is racism.
It's not white people just getting lucky.
Yeah,
I'm okay.
But I would say not that we shouldn't acknowledge it.
Yeah.
So you,
you said earlier about how definitions change.
So we are evolving as a society.
We're getting less sexist and racist and so our threshold for what counts as
sexist and racist is going down.
That's a good thing that should happen.
But I think what we need to call attention to is that when you,
if you lower the threshold faster than the reality changes,
then you make progress.
But yet people feel worse and worse.
And so,
um,
and so I think that's part of what's happening on campus that makes sense.
The,
the progress.
So the,
the,
the loudest protest tend to happen at the most progressive schools.
It's places like Middlebury and Yale and Berkeley.
Um,
and you know,
so I think that we are,
we are,
if you bring in a diverse student body and we're all trying to diversify,
we're all in,
every school I know of is trying very hard to create a very diverse student
body.
So if we do that and we bring people in and we give them a common humanity
approach,
it's going to work great.
Diversity.
If you handle it well,
you,
it can confirm many benefits,
but if you handle it wrong,
if you try to make people see race and other groups more and you attach moral
valence to it and you give them a lot of the stuff they get in the grievance
studies,
of course they're going to be angry.
And of course they're gonna feel that people hate them.
It's a terrible thing to bring people into a university and to teach them,
you know what this institution is white supremacist people have implicit bias
against you.
Wherever you go,
people are going to hate you.
Like,
no,
this is a really bad thing to do to create an open,
trusting,
inclusive,
diverse environment,
right?
The right thing to do would be to emphasize how foolish racism really is and
about how damaging it is,
not just to our culture,
but to use an individual to look at people in that way and not open your heart
and your mind to all these different races.
And I think one of the worst examples of modern racism that's gone on checked is
what's going on at Harvard with Asian students or Asian students are instead of,
instead of being completely neutral in terms of how they approach all these
races,
Asian students actually have to try harder to get into Harvard and there because
there's so many of them and they're doing so well.
Yeah.
They're being punished for excelling,
which is really racist.
I mean you're,
it's,
it's racist against the people that are doing the best,
which is really crazy.
And there are minority,
which is even more crazy.
And because of their culture,
because they're so hard working and they're not in general than the,
not the type to be really loud and protests these things.
Right.
It's gone on the target targeted to the point where now they've had to have a
class action lawsuit.
That's right.
So,
you know,
my hope,
again,
I'm a 20th century person.
My hope is that as time goes on,
we'll get past all of this.
You have to be a 21st century person.
Oh,
you have to.
Well,
okay.
But you know what,
the there are,
okay,
wait,
moral cultures evolve and they don't always evolve in a positive way.
And so I think the evolution late 20th century was incredibly positive.
Um,
and I think we are,
I think young people are losing touch with some of the hard one lessons of the
past.
Um,
so I'm not going to say,
oh,
we have to just accept whatever morality is here.
I still am ultimately a liberal in the sense that what I dream of is a society
in which people are free to create lives that they want to live and they're not
forced to do things.
They're not shamed.
Um,
there's a minimum of conflict and we make room for each other.
If we're going to have a diverse society,
we've really got to be tolerant and make room for each other.
That's my dream.
Um,
and I think in the last five or 10 years we've gotten really far from that.
I mean the,
you know,
my first book,
the happiness hypothesis was about 10 ancient ideas.
Um,
and you know,
ones that were too judgmental,
you know,
judge not lest ye be judged.
Uh,
but I think the new version of that,
if there was a 21st century Jesus,
he'd say,
judge a lot more judge all the time,
judge harshly,
don't give anyone the benefit of the doubt and don't let anyone judge you like
that is not going to be a recipe for a functioning society.
So No,
I do not accept this aspect of 21st century morality.
Well you're,
you're obviously much more entrenched in it than I am.
Um,
my hope,
and this might be naive,
is that what these far left and far like the really extreme,
what it represents is the,
the,
the extreme poles of this shifting thing so that the whole thing is going to
move closer to a better place and you're always going to have really extreme,
but you're always going to have white supremacy and you always going to have
extreme social
justice people.
You're suggesting it's a pendulum that I,
some things are pendulums,
some are not.
Yeah.
Okay.
So there are problems of progress.
Um,
there are some things that are kind of one way.
So,
um,
you know,
so I'm Kinda,
I'm often pessimistic about certain social trends,
but I'm very influenced by Steve Pinker,
who I know you've had on the show.
Uh,
and,
uh,
Matt Ridley and others who say,
look,
the arc of progress is amazingly rapid,
is all good.
And you know,
Nick Kristoff just had a column that last year was the best year in human
history if you look at overall human welfare.
So that's all true.
Um,
but there are certain things that happened with progress that lead to certain
countervailing trends that are not like pendula.
Uh,
and so for example,
um,
okay,
here's one.
Um,
uh,
kids,
it's,
it,
it seems pretty clear that that human beings need a certain amount of hardship,
stress and challenge in order to develop basic human abilities.
Um,
kids who are neglected and abused are,
are damaged.
I mean,
if,
if it goes beyond certain limits,
uh,
you,
you have chronic stress,
you can have brain damage.
So we as we've,
as we've gotten rid of a lot of the worst things,
that's great,
but as we're making life better and better and easier and easier for kids is
we're protecting them from more and more.
We're,
we're preventing them from basically expanding their abilities and so it's
possible that as we,
as we get wealthier and safer and more humane and more caring and as we have
smaller and smaller families,
as we get richer all over the world so that you have two parents spending all
this time with one kid,
it's possible that we are interfering with kids' development to the point where
we might have an epidemic of anxiety and depression that could happen.
Oh wait a second.
It has,
so you know,
I think that there are certain problems of progress that are not pendula.
They change things and those changes have some negative repercussions that we're
going to have to actively fix.
It's not going to swing back by itself.
What concerns me
when you're talking about all these ideas is that there's a restriction on how
you are able to communicate to children or to students I should say,
to young people,
um,
how their minds work and how they're there,
how these patterns can form and how,
you know,
this,
this pattern can be ultimately damaging to them,
but yet it feels rewarding in the act of doing it.
And that their own patterns that they're involved in right now might be
incredibly problematic for them in the future.
But if you bring it up,
you're criticizing who they are,
who they are as a human,
you're disregarding your white privilege,
you're doing all these different things that you can't really do.
You,
you,
you're doing all these things that could run into these problems with this sort
of new paradigm.
And w w what,
how do you,
how do you mitigate that when you teaching kids?
Like how do you,
how do you talk to them about the way the mind works when it's involving these
critical things that are like incredibly sensitive to discuss today?
Um,
okay.
So let's,
uh,
you might be talking about like issues like race and sex,
race and sex and gender and,
okay,
let's go back to the beginning.
Let's start with child development and let's,
let's,
let's start with,
um,
what should we be doing with kids to make them tougher so that,
you know,
as they live in the world is a safer and safer cars are safer,
the death rate for kids is,
has been plummeting for all and we'll all causes other than suicide,
which has gone up.
Um,
so as kids live in a safer and safer world,
they also have the internet,
which is going to expose them to virtual insults for ever and ever.
So how are we going to raise kids to be maximally effective in this new 21st
century world,
which is physically very safe but virtually unsafe.
Okay.
How are we gonna do that?
Um,
and I think the key idea that we need to put on the table here and that I think
everybody who works with kids needs to keep in mind every day is antifragility.
I know you've talked about that on this show before,
but I'll just,
I should,
I can just give a very brief explanation of it cause it's such an important
concept.
Um,
so,
uh,
antifragility lot of listeners will know is a word coined by Naseem to lab.
The Guy who wrote the Black Swan,
um,
because there are certain systems and he was,
I think he was motivated by the collapse of the banking system.
So he had predicted the collapse because he said the banking system is really
convoluted and it's never been tested.
A system needs to be tested,
challenged,
shocked in order to then develop defenses against it.
And our system has not been tested.
So if anything goes wrong,
it's all gone down.
All right.
You reference him quite a few times.
Yes,
that's right.
He's really concept of venture,
fragile.
That's right.
It's a key idea in,
in our book and if I find,
as I talk about this around the country,
once you explain this to people who work with kids,
like everybody gets it right away.
All right.
So,
so to lab says there is no word for this property.
He says,
we,
we know that some things are fragile.
And so like if you have a glass of a wine glass on the table,
you knock it over.
It breaks.
Okay.
It doesn't get better in any way.
And so,
uh,
you know,
you don't give kids a wineglass.
You give them a plastic sippy cup because plastic is resilient.
But if a kid knocks over sippy cup,
it doesn't get better in any way.
And to let wanted to know what's the word for things that do get better when you
knock them over.
And the classic example is the immune system.
So the immune system is an incomplete system.
It's a miracle of evolution that we have this system for making antibodies.
Um,
but it doesn't know exactly what to be reactive to.
That has to be set by childhood experience.
And so if you keep your kids in a bubble and you use bacterial wipes and you
don't let them be to bacteria,
you're crippling the system.
The system has to get knocked over.
It has to get challenged,
threatened.
It has to have,
uh,
and it has to learn how to,
expand its abilities.
And so,
um,
so this is why peanut allergies are going up.
Yeah.
Those are really shocking part of your book.
That's right.
It's stunning how fast this happened.
Please explain that to people.
The whole peanut allergy thing.
Yeah.
So peanut allergies used to be really rare and most of us,
you know,
older folk,
we brought peanut butter sandwiches to school.
Uh,
and when my son Max started preschool in,
uh,
2008,
you know,
they went on and on about no nuts,
nothing that touched and not nothing that looks like a nut,
nothing that has the word nutty.
I mean,
it was crazy how defensive they were about nuts.
And as we write in the book,
I thought back on that and I said,
wait a second,
like,
why?
You know,
we're freaking out about nuts.
And the more we freak out about it,
the higher the allergy rate goes.
And it turns out there was a study done and published in 2015 where the
researchers noticed that the allergy to nuts is only going up in countries that
tell pregnant women to avoid nuts.
And they thought,
well,
maybe that's why.
And so they did a controlled experiment.
They've got about 600 women who had given birth recently and ha and whose kids
were at higher risk of an allergy cause they had eczema or some other,
you know,
immune system sort of issue.
So about 300 of them are told standard advice,
your kids at risk,
the peanut allergy,
so you should not eat peanuts while you're lactating and keep peanuts weaken
from your kid.
And the other half were told,
here is an Israeli snack food.
It's a popcorn with a peanut,
a peanut powder dusting on the outside,
give it to your kids,
starting at,
you know,
three or four months or whenever they're ready to eat.
And so,
and they monitor them,
they made sure that they weren't,
you know,
fatal reactions or,
or,
or strong reactions.
And then,
uh,
at the age of five,
they gave them all a very thorough immunological test.
And of the ones who followed the standard advice,
17% had a peanut allergy.
They would have to watch out for peanuts for the rest of their lives.
That's just such a high number because these were,
because these were kids who are already predisposed and but the half that were
predisposed,
but give him peanut powder,
3% just 3% had a peanut allergy at age five.
In other words,
we could almost wipe out peanut allergies by giving peanut powder to kids and
see it just a few months ago in science.
The front page article was on doing that.
And so again,
good intentions and bad ideas.
We're trying to protect her kids soap.
Oh,
keep them away from peanuts.
But that's exactly the wrong advice because kids are antifragile and so we're
doing the same thing.
The real issue was the people that have an actual severe allergy of what's your
child.
Yeah.
Yes.
But that's what the science article was about,
was that a exposure therapies are being tested and they are the most effective.
So you just,
you just have to start slow.
So you give them a very small,
exactly.
Yeah.
Cause it was on a plane once and they informed us that they didn't want us to
even eat peanuts on the plane because there someone on the plane that was so
allergic,
right.
That if you eat peanuts and you chew it and it's in the air,
it could adversely affect that person.
Yeah.
And that could well be true.
So I have no objection to that.
But the reason we got to that point is because we started banning peanuts long
ago.
So this is one of these have,
I'm not sure if it's a problem of progress,
but as we know it's not necessarily,
but,
um,
but it's an example of antifragility.
Right.
Okay.
So now let's bring this to the playground.
All right.
So,
um,
you know,
when,
when you and I were kids,
you know,
boys and girls have different social interactions,
but boys tease each other,
right.
And salt each other.
You throw around insults,
right?
Yeah.
And that's part of developing to be a boy.
Now if it turns into bullying like a bunch of kids or why are after one kid day
after day?
Okay,
that's terrible.
We have to do something about that.
I'm not saying bullying is okay,
but as we've cracked down on bullying and as we've gotten more and more
sensitive about harm in general,
we're cracking down on any kind of teasing,
cruelty exclusion.
So my kids go to New York City public schools,
uh,
which are generally pretty good.
Um,
but on the playground,
you know,
there's a monitor and the playground monitor,
if there's conflict,
he comes and checks it out.
If a kid is crying,
he checks it out.
Um,
you know,
seems like a good thing to do,
but it's like treating kids like they're allergic to peanuts.
Kids have to have thousands and thousands of conflicts.
They have to be exposed to insults and exclusion and teasing.
And if you can imagine,
if you could keep your daughter in a protective tank when nobody would tease her
or insult or hurt her feelings for 18 years,
would you do it?
Absolutely not.
It's not.
It's,
it's important that they do experience.
Some assholes,
they just have to know.
But the,
on the flip side,
there are certain people that are damaged for the rest of their life,
by bullies and some like I have a friend,
um,
and his brother used to beat him up when,
when they lived together and it still fucks with him to this day.
And he's in his 50s.
He,
I think he has a certain level of depression that's directly correlated.
Right?
I mean,
I can't say about your friend,
but the research shows,
the research does show that,
um,
bullying can leave permanent scars.
So there are a couple of things we have to keep our eye on.
Kids are antifragile yes,
but,
um,
two things.
One is they need challenges that are graded to their level of ability.
So if they're overwhelmed and if the suffering goes on day after day.
So if kids are bay,
if their brain is bathed in cortisol.
So cortisol is a normal stress hormone.
You have to experience stress,
you have to have cortisol.
And then it drops goes up and down,
up and down.
But kids who were raised either in an environment where they're bullied or
they're abuse at home,
they don't have a secure attachment relationship,
then they get brain damage,
then you,
you,
you're hurting kids if it's chronic.
So I'm in no way saying bullying as,
okay,
I know you to keep,
you got to keep the line right.
But,
but again,
you have to look at each institution.
So each school is not thinking,
hmm,
how can we carefully draw the line between bullying and valuable sorts of
conflict?
No.
They're thinking,
well,
if we do this well,
we get sued.
Right?
And if we're not really careful that bullying,
we're gonna get sued.
And so let's overreact.
Let's go this way.
Yeah.
That's unfortunate.
Really.
Um,
but how do you decide how much bullying is accept?
Like snake venom,
but giving them a little bit so they develop a tolerance?
Yeah.
Well,
so there's,
um,
we,
so we did some research on bullying.
We didn't put it in the book because while we suspect that anti bullying
policies that,
that go too far and that band conflict,
while we suspect that those are harmful,
we couldn't prove that.
So we didn't put this in the book,
but the,
the traditional definitions of bullying are actually pretty reasonable.
Uh,
I'm,
I hope I can remember it exactly.
It's like there's a,
uh,
there's like a power differential and it's a chronic,
you know,
it goes on for,
multiple,
multiple days.
Um,
and originally there was a,
actually a threat of violence,
um,
had to be at least a threat of violence.
I think that was the original definition.
Uh,
and then that was expanded gradually.
Um,
um,
so it doesn't have to be necessarily threat of violence,
but it has expanded so far that like,
my kids use the term.
If one kid is mean to another,
they'll call that bullying.
And that's too far.
So I think you have to keep your eye on the key features too far.
If a kid is mean,
yeah,
you can't call it.
So,
um,
so,
uh,
like on the,
on the playground for my daughter,
the girls would form these clubs.
And so my daughter was in the Kitty cat club that got what three girls called
themselves and they'd be in a corner and they'd say,
Oh,
you can't,
you know,
you can't join us.
You're not in the Kitty cat club.
Um,
that's mean that's exclusion,
right?
We can't have that.
Right.
So the,
so you don't have to like allow everyone in your group because you don't want to
be a bully.
That's,
yeah.
I don't know.
They called that bullying,
but her teacher had a conversation with them.
Now she didn't,
I don't think she exactly ordered them.
Never exclude.
So I mean it'd be okay if you use it as a grounds for discussion but increased.
But some schools have even tried to discourage the existence of best friends
because if you have best friends,
you're excluding others.
That's hilarious.
It is hilarious.
But again,
it's if you fail to understand that kids are antifragile and you think,
oh my,
you know,
there's a rise of anxiety and depression in girls are cutting themselves at such
high rates.
You know,
we've got it.
We've got to relieve them of stress.
Like no,
that's not the right way to go about it.
And there really is an epidemic of,
of kids that grew up in that error of participation trophies where everyone one
and there,
there's a lot of parents that don't want to see their children lose.
Yeah.
But that's a giant and learning opportunities.
Actually.
If you think the goal is to cultivate self esteem directly,
you're crippling the kid.
I'm giving your kid self esteem is not beneficial.
Um,
in fact,
if kids have high self esteem but it's unstable,
then they're actually more likely to be violent.
They have more problems.
You don't want to build self esteem,
which you to build his capacities.
You want to give them abilities and skills that they do things that then
indirectly give them self esteem and compassion.
Right.
I mean,
how do you,
how do you teach that?
How do you teach it?
Well,
there are lots and lots.
I mean it's one of the biggest things that is happening in schools is efforts to
teach compassion.
I don't know.
I've not surveyed the research.
I don't know if they work.
I don't know.
Um,
so look in general,
kids learn from experience,
but adults want to teach them directly.
And so there's all these efforts to teach compassion.
I have no idea if they work.
Um,
but I would think that doing things together,
uh,
and um,
this is a point made by Peter Gray and expert on play who co founded,
uh,
let grow.org a wonderful organization.
And I hope we can talk about,
um,
one way that kids learn compassion is by playing with each other when there's no
adults who can step in,
where they have to look out for each other to keep the game going.
But when there are adults present who are supervising,
then if there's a conflict,
the skills that kids need to learn are,
how do you make your case to get the adult to come in on your side?
And this is called moral dependence.
So one of the best ways that kids learn compassion,
cooperation,
tolerance,
teamwork,
leadership is free play,
unsupervised,
free play.
And that's what kids did from time immemorial.
Certainly throughout the 20th century up until the 1990s like when you,
so,
uh,
Xos,
you,
how old were you?
Where'd you grow up first of all?
Well,
I'll all over the place.
Honestly,
I was born in New Jersey,
lived there till seven San Francisco from seven to 11 period.
Seven Toilet Messa keep here.
Okay.
When you lived in San Francisco where you allowed outside?
We were allowed to like go to a friend's house.
Could you and your friends go places?
Yeah,
I was a latch key kid.
Okay.
Yeah.
My parents were gone all day and so they would be arrested if they did that
right.
When I was eight years old,
I did a magic show on fisherman's wharf by myself.
Fantastic.
What do you wait,
what happened?
A dodged a bunch of bullets.
What do you mean have,
I almost got molested.
Some guy tried to,
some guy tried to abducted me.
Wait,
wait.
Literally tried to obtain,
yeah.
Was in a library.
Some guy tried to get me to go out to his car with them to check out some books
and some,
a lady librarian saved me.
She screamed out,
Joseph,
you get away from that man.
He just got out of jail.
I ran off.
He was super creepy.
But you know,
I was eight.
I didn't understand what was going on.
I just thought he had some good books.
Okay.
Okay,
good.
Right.
So this is a nice example of how we've made progress.
Yeah.
So you know,
a lot of what I'm saying,
we're saying the book is we have to let kids out now.
Yes,
there is.
There are dangerous out there.
And so kids have to learn.
Um,
you actually can talk to strangers.
It's not
talk to strangers.
Just never,
ever go off with them.
Never under any circumstances.
But he,
you know,
he really,
the problem with talking to strangers is when you're eight,
you don't understand manipulation.
You,
you
think of adults as being someone who's got,
you can count on.
Okay.
So,
so back then we were negligent in that we just,
we sent our kids out and we didn't think about the dangerous.
Now the dangerous are actually extremely low,
at least the danger of abduction.
Um,
the number of kids who were abducted in America each year is on the order of a
hundred.
Now many more are abducted by the noncustodial parent.
But what you're talking to as a stranger,
now there's,
there are creeps out there.
There are guys who masturbate.
I mean there's all kinds of creeps out there,
but abductions is extraordinarily rare.
And so yes,
we have to deal with,
we have to teach kids.
But what happened was there was a crime wave when you and I were growing up,
there was actually a lot of crime in this country and the seventies and eighties
there was a lot of crime.
And then the crime wave begins to end rapidly in the 1990s and just as it's
ending,
we changed our norms to say,
if a kid is outside and there's no adult watching him,
that kid is likely to be abducted.
And therefore the parents are responsible.
The parents can be arrested or at least child protective services should pay
them a visit.
So,
um,
just as the crime rate was ending and rates of all kinds of crazy violence were
plummeting,
we locked our kids up and we said,
you're not going to be able to have the kind of experience that you most need in
order to become an independent functioning adult.
And so we don't know why depression,
anxiety and suicide are skyrocketing,
um,
for teenagers,
especially teenage girls.
But the combination of overprotection and then social media seems to be the main
part of the example.
So I totally sympathize with the fact that yeah,
you know,
there are,
there are risks out there,
but the risk of overprotection is kills a lot more kids.
There was a story that I read about,
I want to say the kids were eight and 10 and they were walking home in New York
City and the police officer stopped them and talk to them and then eventually
interviewed their parents and said,
why are your children walking home?
He's like,
cause I taught him how to walk home.
I showed him how to get home.
Like this is a,
this is a valuable thing to give them the independence to leave school together.
They look out for each other and then they go home together and you know,
the cops were making it like these people were negligent and criminal and they
were saying,
no,
I'm trying to prepare my child for the world.
So it's uh,
it's sort of a debate about the philosophy of raising human beings and exposing
them to a certain amount of independence and a certain amount of personal
sovereignty.
That's right.
And so this is,
this is,
um,
I think the most important lesson that Greg and I hope will come from our book
is that if you see the world is dangerous and threatening and you raise your
kids accordingly,
you're going to raise emotionally stunted kids who are at much higher risk of
depression,
anxiety,
and suicide.
So stop doing that.
We got to stop doing that.
Unfortunately,
it's hard to stop doing that because if we let our kids outside,
we can be arrested.
Now,
that happens very rarely,
but it does happen or more concerning your kids.
Can Be harmed.
That's extremely rare,
but it can happen.
And through the people that does happen to the idea that it's extremely rare,
it's not comforting.
Well that's,
so we think about probabilities in very ineffective ways actually.
Do we have those graphs?
I sent in some graphs of depression,
anxiety rates.
Um,
so,
um,
if we think that kids are at risk of harm from letting them out,
but we don't see that there at risk of harm from keeping them in if we're going
to make the wrong decision.
Right.
So there's a silence secret sort of invisible harm of coddling them.
Exactly.
And then there's the small percentage of possible harm that you could get if you
go out into the world.
Right.
So,
okay,
so you're raising your kids here.
What,
what's your policy on letting them out?
Man,
it's slippery.
Hello?
How old is your oldest?
A while I haven't grown one who's 22 and then I have a 10 and an eight.
Okay.
And it's hard,
man,
because I don't even like when they go over on sleepovers over a friend's house.
Scary.
Whose problem is that?
It's everybody's problem.
You know,
it's,
uh,
well I mean the parents,
I mean we're,
we're pretty selective about the parents,
but there's a lot of parents that don't pay attention to their kids at all.
Meaning they just tune out and they get on the phone.
The kids are sticking forks into the fucking outlets.
And you know,
there's,
there's a lot of weirdness when it comes to the styles of that people have been
raising their children.
What does this,
uh,
this graph he just pulled out?
So,
you know,
um,
depressive episodes.
So I guess I'll just narrate it for people to listen to that watching video,
you know,
so you said before,
it's like a virus came out of nowhere and that is sort of what it's been like.
Um,
so what's happening in America and I know what's happening at the same in
Britain and Canada.
I haven't looked at other,
other places yet,
haven't dug into those stats.
Um,
what's happening is that rates of depression and anxiety were fairly stable,
uh,
from the nineties through the early two thousands.
And what you see here,
and this is a graph that's in our book,
is that the,
uh,
the percentage of kids aged 12 to 17 in America who met the criteria for having
a major depressive episode.
That is they're given a symptom checklist with nine symptoms.
And if you say yes to five of them,
uh,
you know,
feeling hopeless and couldn't get out of bed.
Um,
if you say yes to five or more,
you're,
you're considered to have had a major depressive episode.
And what you see is that the rate for boys is around 5%.
And then around 2011 it starts going up and now it's around 7%,
which is actually a somewhat substantial increase.
Uh,
but as you can see in the graph,
the line for girls starts off higher cause girls have more mood disorders,
more anxiety,
depression.
Boys have more antisocial behavior,
alcoholism,
crime and violence.
But girls turn it,
it's called an internalizing disordered girls basically make themselves
miserable.
Boys make other people miserable.
Uh,
the gross rate is higher,
but it was stable from 2000 releasing that graph from 2005 through 2010 and then
right around 2011,
2012 starts going up and it goes way up to the point where it goes up from about
12% to now about 20% of American teenage girls have had a major depressive
episode in the last year,
one in five.
So this is huge.
Okay,
next slide.
Now,
let's look just a college students.
So this is more selective.
These are kids who've made it into college.
And what we see is that in 2010 and 20 and 2012 when college students,
we're all millennials,
the rates were pretty low.
This is,
do you have a psychological disorder?
And they didn't specify they or they said such as depression.
Uh,
and so we see about two to 3% of the boys,
uh,
the college men,
and about 5% of a five to 6% of college women say yes to that question.
That's when it was millennials.
But beginning of 2013,
Gen z begins arriving.
That's kids born in 1995,
uh,
Gen z begins arriving.
And so by 2016,
colleges are almost all gen z and the rates shoot up way up.
Yeah.
We're looking at these charts right now and folks who are just listening.
The,
it's like,
it's a,
like a jump ramp for a BMX racer.
I mean,
it really is crazy for whim out of nowhere.
And it hits at 2012 it goes on a very sharp upward angle.
Right?
It goes from six less than 6% to almost 15% in the space of four years.
That's crazy.
It's crazy.
Uh,
oh,
you can't say that.
That's an [inaudible] can't say crazy fucking nuts.
And I say that.
No,
because some people might have a nut allergy.
Oh boy.
Um,
ludicrous.
It's preposterous.
It's really frightening.
Yeah.
And so this has huge ramification.
Now let me just make clear,
I think we have another,
another slide there who bring up the next one.
Okay.
So,
um,
some people say,
uh,
oh,
come on you guys.
Or catastrophizing.
The increased isn't real.
It's just that,
you know,
this generation,
they're really comfortable talking about mental illness.
Um,
and so the fact that they say they're depressed just means they're comfortable.
It doesn't mean that there's an epidemic.
I've heard this argument that it's just a,
an argument of recognition rather than have
perfectly,
that's right.
Diagnostic criteria changed perfectly reasonable argument.
Is it true?
Well,
let's look at behavior.
So with this graph show is,
is the number of boys out of 100,000 who are admitted to a hospital every year
because they cut,
they deliberately harmed themselves.
They had to be hospitalized.
And what you see here is that um,
there is no change over time.
So boys,
these graphs from 2001 to 2015,
the lines are flat for all the different age groups.
Um,
and just notice that the highest rates are around 280 out of 100,000 per year.
That's the situation for boys.
Next graph,
Bang.
The situation for girls is really,
really different.
So the averages are higher.
So self harm has always been more of a girl thing than a boy thing.
Um,
you know,
boys are except for suicide.
Exactly.
We'll get to that.
That's right.
That's next.
So,
uh,
we look at self harm.
What you see here is that the rates were fairly stable up until 2009,
and then bang just isn't the same thing.
The rates for girls go shooting up.
So the rate for 15 to 19 year old girls is up 62% since 2009.
Um,
now notice the rate the millennials,
that is the rate for the oldest girls age 20 to 24.
That's only up 17%.
So whatever happened,
it's not effecting the millennials,
it's affecting Gen z.
I think ways there when it hit the advanced key cause I think there's one number
missing there.
Ah,
okay.
I'll just uh,
no go forward.
Okay.
The number of air it is,
there,
it is.
The rate for the youngest girls.
Check that out.
Now the youngest scores,
these are 10 to 14 year old girls.
These are preteens.
Okay.
They didn't use to cut themselves.
They used to have very low rates,
but bang,
beginning in 2010 it shoots up,
it's up 189% it is nearly tripled in the last five or six years.
Once they're gone,
we don't know for sure,
but the reason why,
so because of the huge sex difference deleting candidate and the timing.
You look at that timing is social media.
So if you look at what happened in this country and all around the world,
um,
Facebook opens up to the world in 2006 you don't have to be a college student,
but very few teenagers have a Facebook account.
In 2006 2007 the iPhone comes out,
but it's very expensive and very few teenagers have won.
By 2010 2011 around half of American teenagers have an iPhone or Samsung,
they have a smartphone and they have access to social media in middle school.
Because even though for Facebook and Instagram,
I think the minimum age is and was 13 you know,
I mean my,
my son is 12 a lot of his friends have Instagram.
You just lie.
So middle school kids are now getting on social media by 2010 2011 you've got a
lot of them.
And that's what I think is the main cause of this because social media does not
really affect boys very much,
but man,
does it affect girls?
Why is,
uh,
so if you look at,
so a couple of reasons.
First,
look at the nature of aggression within the sexes.
Boys bullying is physical.
Okay?
Boys are physically dominating and then the risk is that they're going to get
punched.
Okay,
so you give everybody an iPhone.
What do they do with it?
Games and porn.
They don't use it to hurt each other.
Um,
boys,
your boys.
That's right.
It doesn't affect their bullying.
But girls aggression that girls are actually as aggressive as boys.
There's research for from the eighties and nineties on this.
If you include relational aggression,
girls don't bully each other by threatening to punch each other in the face.
Girls bully each other by damaging the other girls' social relationships,
spreading rumors,
spreading lies,
spreading a doctorate,
photograph,
saying bad things,
excluding them.
It's relational aggression.
And so it's always been really hard to be a middle school student.
It's always been harder to be middle school girl than a middle school boy.
Okay?
So beginning around 2010,
2011,
we throw in this brand new thing into the mix.
Okay girls,
here's this beautiful thing in your hand and here's all these programs where you
can damage anyone social relationships anytime of the day or night with
deniability from an anonymous account go at,
at girls.
And so,
um,
the nature of girls bullying is hypercharged by social media and that's one
mechanism.
The other two mechanisms,
um,
are the social comparison because it's always been hard to be a teen girl
emerging with beauty standards and impossible beauty standards.
And when we were kids,
you had impossible beauty standards that these models were all doctored up and
then Photoshop.
Okay?
So you've got these impossible beauty standards out there,
but beginning of social media,
and especially in recent years,
your own friends can put on a filter and Instagram to make their lips big or
their skin cleaner,
their eyes bigger.
So your own friends are more beautiful than they are in real life.
You feel uglier.
So that's the social comparison of beauty.
And then probably the biggest single one is the fear of missing out,
the fear of being left out.
So all kids are subject to this.
Everyone's concerned about whether they're included,
whether they're,
they're excluded,
but girls are much more sensitive.
And so suddenly when everybody is tracking each others who was invited,
who's there,
and especially any program in which a girl puts something out and then waits to
see what other people say about it,
that is what's really damaging.
I think we'd,
again,
let me stress,
we don't know for sure there are some experiments on this,
but it's mostly correlational stuff we're talking about here.
Correlational data.
Um,
but the overall experience of being a girl who was born in 1995 or later and got
this stuff in middle school is different from being a girl born in 1990 let's
say we didn't get this stuff til college.
Are you concerned that this is a trend that as technology becomes more and more
invasive and with these new technologies as they emerge,
that this is going to be worse?
Yes,
yes.
But it doesn't have to be so,
so I think in the last two years were really waking up to this,
um,
the founders of this technology.
It's really interesting.
So first of all,
it's important to note as many people have read the,
a lot of the creators of this technology do not let their kids have it.
So they know that these things were made to be addictive.
They're made to grab eyeballs and not let go.
So,
um,
that's one thing we all wish,
keep that in mind,
that the makers of this are wary of it.
Second,
they've gotten more and more addictive as they've gotten better and better as
they've evolved.
Um,
so they're getting more and more.
And Fortnite is an example of,
of,
uh,
you know,
extremely addictive game.
Um,
um,
and it does.
But,
uh,
so when you,
if you've ever been to a,
um,
a casino and you've seen kids,
you've seen people sitting at those machines,
like zombies just you know,
hour after hour pulling that crank.
Cause there were psychologists working out the variable reinforcement schedule
for the gambling companies,
psychologists,
they are helping companies manipulate he users.
And that's happening to our kids too.
They're,
they're manipulated to stay on the device.
So once we're beginning to realize this,
the nature of these technologies,
the fact that what is good for adults may be terrible for 12 year olds,
10 year olds.
And once we realize that these things are so attractive that they crowd out all
the other healthy activities like playing outside,
playing with groups of friends.
Um,
once we realize that,
I think,
and I hope we'll get some reasonable norms.
And what I'd like to propose,
this is fantastic to be able to talk to so many people.
Um,
what I'd like to propose is if you have kids,
especially if you have kids under about 16,
please do what you can to talk with other parents.
And especially with the principle of any schools,
you know and say we need some sensible norms because we can't solve this problem
by ourselves.
So I want to keep my kids off social media,
but my son says,
well most of my friends or have Instagram accounts now,
if it was every friend and he was the only one who was excluded,
you'll be really hard for me to stick to my guns.
I would do,
it would be really hard.
Whereas if it was only a few of his friends and most of them weren't,
it would be so easy.
And I hear this from parents over and over.
I don't want my kid on social media,
but I don't want her to be left out.
And so if the principal would just say,
parents,
please,
this is getting,
this is getting out of hand.
This is harming kids.
Look at the data,
look at the suicide rates,
look at the,
look at the self harm rates.
We've got to do something.
What do you do?
A couple of things.
I think it's pretty a couple of pretty simple norms.
One,
all devices out of the bedroom by a set time,
at least half an hour before bed.
There is no reason why kids should have an iPhone or a computer or a screen in
their bedroom because so many kids are attracted to it.
They'll check their status overnight and it interrupts their sleep.
We can't be having teenagers who have interrupted sleep that there's just no
benefit from that.
Gave my daughter a fitbit,
my 10 year old to a monitor,
all sorts of different things.
She was interested in it.
So we got her one for Christmas and um,
she slept five and a half hours the first night she had it on cause we could
check.
We're like,
what are you doing?
She's checking the fifth.
What is,
what's going on here?
I'm like,
this is not good.
Like you can't wear this now.
And she's like trying to make all these arguments to keep,
but I'm like,
listen,
she goes,
it's not distracting me.
I go,
if it's not distracting you,
then you shouldn't care if you don't have it on.
Right.
Because then it's not going to mean anything.
And then there's like this like a shit.
Like she got checkmated that's right now because these things are so
interesting.
It's so addictive.
I had one of those goddamn watches,
those apple watches I had it on for one day while I was doing the podcast.
It kept vibrating.
I'm like,
Oh my God,
I'm getting text messages on my wrist,
my wrist.
Yeah.
So great.
And your brain is all developed adult.
Sketchy.
Okay.
But imagine if you're a 10 or 11 year old kid and you put something out there
and you want to know,
did you know,
did bill like it yet?
You know,
why did,
why did Mary like bills but not like,
so that's rule number one.
You've got to get devices out of the bedroom.
Yeah.
Give him an old fashioned alarm clock.
Let him wake up with an alarm cuts one.
Um,
to no social media till high school.
There is no reason why kids in middle school or elementary school should have
Instagram,
Facebook,
snapchat,
any of those.
They can text each other.
Like when we were kids,
he'd call each other on the phone.
That's fine.
They can text each other,
but there should be no social media till high school cause it's a,
it's a social dilemma.
It that we can't solve alone.
We only saw the,
if there's an agreement among parents and guidance,
the principal please parents don't give your kid and Instagram.
Yeah.
My only concern is that they're not going to learn how to mitigate it or how to
navigate it rather if we say nothing till high school and then when they get
into high school then they,
they're confronted with it.
I would like them to have some skills or at least some understanding of what's
going on.
So,
so I'm not saying don't let them have access to these machines.
I'm not saying don't let him know.
I know exactly what you're saying.
You're saying they won't allow you to have social media.
Yeah.
And how about this?
Um,
the bullying that takes place in middle school is primitive and destructive.
Uh,
and the bullying that takes place in late high school is a lot less and is not
the same way.
Why do you say it is?
Well mills like middle school kids are just coming into this.
Um,
there's some research on gene twinkie has a book called ign and she has some
data in there that suggests that when you get social media in college,
it doesn't seem to harm you,
but when you got it and your preteen years it does.
And so,
and she thinks that it's in part,
the nature of the bullying is such,
um,
so you know,
sure,
we want them to know how to deal with this,
but you know,
they can learn it pretty quickly when they're 15.
It's not like they need a running start from 11 to 15.
So I just see no good whatsoever coming from social media in middle school and I
see a lot of harm.
If you want your look,
I go around the country to talk about this.
The almost,
the rule now is when someone in someone says,
oh,
well my daughter's in high school and you know,
she's had it.
And I say,
how she doing?
Does she have anxiety problems?
The answer's almost always yes.
And if it's not her,
then her friends are all crippled by or suffering from anxiety.
So I think we have to,
you know,
you have to wake cost and benefits.
A few years ago we didn't know for sure about the costs.
Now we do.
Yeah.
No,
you're making total sense.
I'm,
I'm purely playing devil's advocate and I'm on the same page with you.
I don't give,
my kids don't have phones and my 10 year old,
it's shocking how many girls in her class have phones.
Right.
And Facebook accounts and Instagram
and they,
I'll,
I'll say it right now,
her friends are at higher risk than she is of having an anxiety disorder of
being hospitalized because they're going to cut themselves and ultimately
assist.
Yeah.
It's so common and it's most of the kids in school now and when they get older
than 10 the,
the number increases.
Like parents hold out for as long as they can.
But as they get older and the kids want want
phones,
man,
everybody wants a phone.
Okay.
So then he put in a plug.
So I gave my son,
so I'm saying two contradictory things.
One is I'm saying we got to let our kids out,
got to start letting them out at least by age eight,
at least to go with their friends to playground stores.
We've got to start doing this.
Um,
and at the same time I'm saying that the technology has some negative effects.
Okay.
If you're going to send your kid out,
I totally get what you were saying about you're either panic,
like the first time that we let our sign out in the park and then he didn't come
home right when he said like,
and it was real panic.
Um,
in part.
So two things.
One is we have to get used to that because he always does come home.
But secondly,
I didn't realize this when I gave him an iPhone.
My old iPhone,
um,
there's a great little product.
The,
uh,
I'm not,
I don't know if horizon,
no,
they don't make it.
It's an LG makes it,
but it's a Gizmo,
a Gizmo gadget.
Uh,
and so it's a simple,
it's a watch.
It's a,
it's,
it's a big clunky thing,
but my daughter loves wearing it because it's kind of like a James Bond Dick
Tracy thing.
It's a watch.
You press a button,
you turn it on,
you can call three phone numbers.
That's it.
Three,
four so she can call.
And so now I can send it out to get bagels on Sunday morning.
She walks about six blocks in New York City.
It's incredibly safe.
How old is she?
She is nine.
So yeah.
So um,
uh,
and she is a much more independent,
confident girl because of it.
And she is proud of this fact that she is a free range kid.
She can walk around our neighborhood.
I mean we live in Greenwich village,
it's incredibly safe.
Um,
so she can go get bagels and it,
you know,
she has no sense of direction.
So a couple of times when she's been out doing an errand,
she gets lost.
She just presses a button.
Daddy,
I don't know where I am and she's calm and you know,
we've talk it through and I can track her.
That's the the reassuring thing.
I can see on a screen roughly where she is,
so I can say,
you know what do you see?
And I said,
I'll come back this way and she always knows her.
She gets in trouble.
Just walk home and start again.
What are you thinking,
Joe?
Right.
What's,
what's that facial expression for that thing is just children wandering around
on their own.
Yeah.
That has always happened and as they have to do at some point,
I know,
but listen,
look at how you're even reacting to this at what you're,
you're,
you're beaming up and you're adding emotion to your voice and you're smiling as
though it's,
everything's going to be fine.
Everything you're doing this and sort of,
you're not just reassuring.
You're selling it.
You're right.
I am selling it because we as a society bought into a set of beliefs that are
based on false hoods.
The risk to our kids is miniscule.
Someone calculated at present rates of abduction by strangers.
If you put your kid in a car and you go into a store and you leave the windows
open and your kid sitting there in the parking lot,
you'd have to stay in that store for 700,000 years before your kid is likely to
be abducted.
Well,
it does not depend on what neighborhood you live in,
I suppose.
So,
yeah.
But still the point is that there's hardly any actual abduction.
And so actually it's,
this brings up a really important point.
I'd like to say,
um,
you,
one of the sticking points here is that we're afraid to let her kids out because
bad things can happen to us as well as to the kids.
And so I hope that would be the least of your concerns or what number one
concern would be your children's safety,
but you getting in trouble for that hope would be the least of your concerns and
not the least of them.
Because I am selling something.
I'm selling the idea that,
that the,
the gigantic rise in mental illness of teenagers is caused in part because we've
overprotected them.
We have denied them the experiences of independence,
they need to develop their basic social sense.
And so I am selling idea that we've,
we've totally botched this and we need to undo it.
And a big piece of that is we need to be removed from the fear of legal
prosecution.
And so Utah,
the State of Utah passed a year and a half ago.
A year ago.
Yeah.
They passed the first free range kids bill,
which says it puts into state law.
It says,
uh,
I forget what the exact terms,
but the gist of it is a parent cannot be considered to be negligent just by
having the kids be unsupervised.
So if you send your kids out to the park,
you know,
you have to use judge.
Obviously if there's a pattern of neglect,
that's a totally different story.
Right?
But the mere fact that as you just said,
the story about,
well,
I'm teaching my kids to go outside.
I know that they're outside.
I told them to go outside.
You can't be arrested for that.
And until we have legal protections,
it's can be very hard for anyone to do it because they,
you know,
the risk is you could be drawn into months and months of supervision.
Your kids can actually be taken away from you if you give them independence in
some parts of the country.
It's interesting that you taught would be so progressive about that.
Um,
yeah,
I don't know the history behind it.
Such a safe place.
It's one of the reasons why thank [inaudible] that could be so a big part of
this is we don't trust each other anymore.
Um,
you know,
if,
if you don't trust your neighbors,
then you're,
you're not going to let them out.
You're not let your kids,
oof.
Um,
one of the things you talk about,
uh,
in,
in your book about happiness,
it's really interesting is cognitive therapy,
Prozac and meditation.
Those,
those three factors being enormous,
uh,
AIDS in,
acquiring a certain amount of happiness.
You know,
um,
I've,
I found it very refreshing that you,
um,
you also added in Prozac,
you added in ssrs because there's a lot of people that seem to take this
approach with,
um,
any depressants in particular that they're overprescribed,
which I think they probably are.
And that they do more harm than good,
which is debatable,
but the fact that they do do good.
I have had two close friends that were in really bad places and they got on an
Ssri and it cleaned them up and they eventually wean themselves off of her and
now very productive and very happy.
But they were in a place in their life where they,
like my friend Ari put it best,
he's like,
uh,
my brain was broken and he goes,
I needed to fix it.
And I fixed it.
And then once it was fixed,
I realized it was fixed and then I weaned myself off.
That's right.
Yeah.
So in,
in chapter two of the happiness hypothesis,
so the book is based on 10 ancient ideas.
Um,
and one of the ancient ideas is,
um,
uh,
the world is,
but we deem the world is,
uh,
the world is what we deem it.
Um,
it,
with our perceptions,
we make the world,
the world is not an objective thing.
We,
we don't react to the world as an objective fact.
We are at react to it through filters.
And one of the major personality traits is sort of positivity,
negativity or overall happiness.
Some people look at the world,
they see threats,
other people look at the world,
they see opportunities.
And if you take a bunch of kids,
four,
five,
six year old kids and you put some weird toy in front of it,
makes noise.
Some of the kids are going to go towards it and say,
Oh,
what's that?
Some are gonna move away.
Like,
oh,
this could be threatening.
And from that behavior,
you can predict not with a lot of accuracy,
but you can do better than chance.
Who's going to go to the high school prom?
Who is going to be a successful,
uh,
in,
um,
in any sort of social endeavors?
Because some people's brains are set to fear and avoidance.
When your brain is set to see more threats,
you have a bias towards interpreting things negatively.
And if the world is incredibly dangerous,
well that might be adaptive.
But if the world's incredibly physically safe as ours is,
um,
you're losing a lot of opportunities,
you're going to be less successful.
And so the point of that chapter was there are ways you can change your filter,
even though this is highly heritable,
identical twins reared apart,
tend to be pretty similar on these traits,
but you can change your filters.
And so that chapter two of the happiness hypothesis shows the three main ways of
changing your filter.
So it was a meditation,
cognitive therapy,
and SSRS and all three work.
There's a lot of evidence for all three.
Um,
meditation has only good effects.
It's wonderful,
but it's hard.
That is,
I've assigned it to my classes and of most undergraduates,
if they have to do it for a few weeks,
most of them stop a few continue and get benefits.
Cognitive therapy is easier.
Um,
it,
when I've assigned students to do it most have success.
I have a real hard time with that phrase.
It's hard.
That is hard or really do.
Um,
I don't think it's hard.
You find it easy to sit for 20 minutes.
Not easy,
but it's not hard.
Coal Mining's hard.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
We're doing something you hate is hard.
This is just complicated.
I don't think it's hard.
You're right.
Let me use a different word.
Um,
meditation is such that the noncompliance rate ends up being quite high.
Well,
there's a massive,
people have problem with a few things.
One,
discipline to,
um,
avoiding discomfort.
This is a,
this is one of the reasons why people don't like to exercise.
And it's also really just starting exercise cause the actual exercise itself is
kind of pleasure.
Once you develop a habit,
it's a lot of,
yes,
this is,
I think what you have with meditation.
It's this procrastination,
this,
uh,
your brain tries to find ways to avoid whatever difficult,
especially in some strange way,
if it's been shown to be beneficial,
things that have been shown to be beneficial,
your brain wants to avoid.
I do not know why that is,
but things you get,
I have a theory that,
especially when you're growing up,
that you associate work with schoolwork.
Jobs did.
So anytime you have these thoughts in your head,
you're like,
oh,
it's that thing.
It's one of those things.
And they don't want to do,
I want to go play video games,
want to play night,
why don't I have to do the work?
But the doing the work,
really,
it's just a matter of how you interface with it,
how you,
how you view it.
And we're,
it's many,
many years of conditioning that this is mundane,
dreary,
boring horse shit.
When you could be out playing,
you'd be out fun stuff.
No,
that's right.
There's a,
there's a great little scene in the Simpsons where Bart's on a video game and
he's shooting down a state capitals and he's shooting,
you know,
like something appears like,
oh,
there's Halena,
you know,
there's a,
Springfield.
And then at a certain point he says,
wait,
I'm learning.
And he throws it.
Do I like to help with that?
Yes,
exactly.
So that's your thesis.
It's really what it is,
what it is.
I mean,
it's,
it's kind of amazing that we have done such a shitty job teaching kids that we
make school out to be this dreary thing that there they have like a deep voice.
Well,
that's right.
And that's,
and this is Peter Gray's point,
Peter Gray,
this wonderful developmental psychologist at Boston college who thinks that
schools are,
are not designed with kids learning in mind.
Um,
kids learn best from interacting with the world from experience.
We get experience from feedback.
Um,
and so,
uh,
we make learning painful.
And so it,
you know,
an example would be,
like how do you learn to climb a tree?
You know,
when we were kids,
he'd climb a tree and you know,
do you know that feeling when you go out on a branch and a certain point,
you just get the sense that it's about to crack.
Yeah.
Can you pull back?
Okay.
Now imagine that you had a hundred kids who learn how to climb trees by climbing
trees.
You take another hundred kids,
you get in tree climbing class,
but you never let him climb a tree.
Okay.
But you,
you know,
you,
you bring in the world's best experts on tree climbing and they teach these kids
how to climb trees.
Uh,
and then you put them all out and you give him treats to climb.
Um,
I know in general I would put my money on the kids who actually learned from
experience.
Oh,
for sure.
And so,
you know,
the general principle again is that,
well actually here,
I'll bring up one other where the idea of and happiness hypothesis.
I find it really helpful to think of the mind as being divided into parts like a
rider on an elephant.
And the rider is our conscious reasoning.
It's the little guy up on top who has language and it's what we're aware of,
but the elephant is the other 99% of our minds.
And that's almost all automatic processes.
It's intuitions,
it's emotions,
it's habits,
phobias,
all sorts of things.
Um,
and so child development can't be just training the rider for 18 years.
Wisdom,
knowledge,
skill,
competence,
those,
those have to involve training the elephant and when the two work together,
then you get the best results.
And I think we,
we just,
what we've done in America especially is we've said,
we want our kids to be really good in math,
so we're going to teach the math earlier,
let's give the math in kindergarten.
But there's no evidence that that helps it.
There's no evidence that teaching academic skills earlier,
we'll make them advance to a higher level at the end.
What they most need when they're young is to play.
And we've taken that away from them.
We've given them too many afterschool lessons and too much supervision of their
play.
Yeah.
That's the saddest thing in the world is when my kids come home and they're
really frustrated because they have homework,
you know,
10 year olds that have hours of homework.
This is,
you're in school all day.
That's right.
And I don't know how to address that.
I mean,
do you bring it to the teachers and say,
Hey,
you guys are fucking up.
Even though I've never taught anyone ever in class.
I'm telling you,
you're doing it wrong.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
it's a,
it's a case where you certainly need the research and the research.
Uh,
we cover some of the research in chapters eight and nine of the coddling,
the American mind.
Um,
and as far as we can tell to be searched seems to show that they're essentially
no benefits to doing homework in kindergarten and first grade.
Maybe a little bit of like,
you know,
they learned to organize their time,
but barely any by fifth or sixth grade,
there's more evidence that homework is beneficial.
But in between there,
it really isn't clear.
What's really clear is that play free play is beneficial.
So,
um,
so it's hard for you as,
as,
as just one parent to say,
Hey,
don't do this.
But I think as part of a larger program to say,
our kids are being messed up,
look at these graphs,
look at the rates of anxiety and depression.
And you know,
when I talk,
I talk about the book all around.
Um,
you talk,
not people not come up to me and they'll say like,
I'm a guitar teacher.
I've been teaching guitar for 20 years and suddenly like just in the last few
years,
I give them negative feedback and they crack.
So everyone's beginning to notice that our kids are frail and nobody wants this.
And so I think we're going to find people more open to changing what we're
doing.
Boy,
I hope so.
Um,
it's also,
it's got to be so incredibly difficult to cater a lesson where you have,
you know,
30 or 40 kids in the classroom with varying abilities and varying interests and
you're sort of catering a lesson where we trying to excite them about astronomy
or whatever it is you're teaching and,
and get it through into their heads and make it seem fun.
Yeah.
And still teach them.
And then still set them up to have a certain amount of discipline.
And if you're going to enter into the workforce,
you're going to have to do things you don't necessarily want to do while you're
doing it.
That's right.
And if we're in now you add to that the decline of authority of teachers and
principals and you add to that the sense of empowerment that parents have to
find tune control and be involved.
Um,
the,
you know,
their stories now that parents who come to the lunchroom because they want to
see their kid at lunch.
Um,
um,
where,
you know,
where principals and teachers were once,
uh,
you know,
if the principal or if the teacher gives a bad grade,
the parents would assume that it was deserved.
A,
I think there's more of a tendency in recent,
in the last decade or two,
uh,
to have parents who are very competitive,
are concerned about getting the kid into college to complain.
So if you have,
um,
I don't know how general these,
these trends are,
I don't want to overestimate this,
but if you have a general decline of authority of teachers and principals,
now they have less leeway to give negative experiences.
So if someone does,
if someone fails to turn in a paper because they were responsible and you say,
sorry,
f yeah,
that would could be a good learning experience.
Right.
But it could be,
but it'd be devastating for their GPA.
And that's right.
That's probably a good thing though.
It's from
the understand the consequences.
Right,
exactly.
What about teaching children?
How to think.
And why is that not a massive part of the curriculum?
Because I think that's something that I really had to learn on my own.
Um,
and I think it's one of the most valuable things that I've ever learned.
But as I got older,
I always thought,
why didn't I learn this in school?
Okay.
A couple of reasons.
So when,
uh,
in the 1980s,
there was a huge emphasis on teaching critical thinking and we don't hear about
that anymore because nobody found a way to do it.
Um,
so it's not that easy.
Uh,
one of the things I cover in the happiness I in the righteous mind is we're all
designed for confirmation bias.
We're all really good at confirming what we already believe.
Um,
and so,
uh,
it's very hard to train anyone to disconfirm their own hypotheses.
What we really need to think better is the right system,
the right community.
We actually need critics.
So actually here I brought you a copy of a,
of a little book that I coped produced.
All right.
So this is John Stuart Mill wrote one of the most important books in the western
tradition on liberty chapter two.
Avant liberty is the best set of arguments ever made for free speech for why it
is that we need to let people talk and challenged and criticized.
Even if we think they're wrong,
we get smarter from having to rebut them,
whereas if we shut them down,
if we have blasphemy laws,
we get dumber because we never actually faced tests of what we believe.
So this set of arguments in chapter two of on liberty is timeless.
I mean,
we need like mill anticipated every argument that we hear now about why we need
to shut that person down lot,
let that person talk.
And so I thought,
wow,
we need to get this book back out cause coushins don't read this anymore.
Um,
and it's a little bit difficult,
the text.
So I,
um,
I happen to be friends with,
uh,
with Richard Reeves,
who's a mill scholar is at Brookings Institution and,
and he called,
he said,
Jonathan,
I love what you're doing at Heterodox Academy.
If I can be of help,
let me know.
So I said,
well,
actually,
Richard,
would you coed it,
this addition of,
of um,
mills second chapter?
And he said,
yes,
I'd love to.
So he made the selections,
we worked together to like,
to reduce it.
It's only 7,000 words,
so it's easy to read.
And then this wonderful artist,
Dave says,
Sorelli stopped by my office.
He said,
I love what you're doing,
a heterodox academy,
if I can be of help,
let me know.
And I said,
well,
actually could you read this text,
find mills metaphors?
Cause millions is a lot of wonderful metaphors and illustrate them.
And so if you just pass it over,
which is,
it's that camera.
Okay.
So what Dave did was he took a,
he took mills metaphors.
Um,
and so,
you know,
and we've got these like amazing,
graphic cartoon type images of the dynamics of what happens when we shame people
because mill was not concerned about government censorship.
That wasn't a big deal in London in 1859.
It was social censorship just as it is today.
So,
you know,
so Sorelli families made these beautiful illustrations,
uh,
of,
of mill's point.
And so we think that this book,
if this book was assigned,
uh,
in every high school for seniors or every incoming
freshmen class,
uh,
we think that people would think a lot better.
So you want to know how to do critical thinking,
read this book,
um,
and then seek out your opponents,
seek out your critics,
seek out the people who can do for you what you can't do for yourself,
which is challenge your ideas.
Are you concerned with this?
Uh,
the trend that we're seeing now with social media of,
I mean,
I get removing blatant racism and sexism and in certain really awful types of
behavior from certain social media sites,
but at a certain point in time,
it becomes an,
an ideological battle.
And people that lean one way or another want that other side to be silenced.
I'm seeing this way more from the left,
which is very disturbing to me because growing up my family was very liberal,
you know,
and I said,
well,
my formative years in San Francisco was always around hippies.
And I always felt like the people that were on the left with the open minded,
educated ones who were concerned with the future of discourse and humans,
uh,
developing the ability to really flesh out ideas and work their way through
them,
which only happens through three,
four through real free speech,
giving people the ability to express themselves and then deciding whether or not
you agree with that and why you disagree or agree and then speaking your mind
and then everybody works it out together.
This,
this is not necessarily the trend that we're seeing today.
Oh,
that's right.
That's right.
So first let me just say,
you can get this book for free.
At least you can download the pdf if you go to heterodoxacademy.org/mil or you
can get a $3 kindle.
Did you go to Amazon?
Look this up,
it's $3 for the kindle,
or you can buy the art book there too.
Awesome.
That's so cool that you're doing that and allowing people to download it for
free too.
We want to get the word out.
We think this would be,
these are the ideas that are needed.
So onto your question.
Um,
so in part there's an empirical question here,
which I don't know the answer to.
In Europe,
they,
uh,
ban in most they ban hate speech.
So a or you know,
a Holocaust denial.
There's certain things that are illegal to crime.
Um,
and in America we don't,
now it's an empirical question,
meaning it's open to actual investigation.
Um,
does banning it,
push it underground and let the people feel that they are victims of being
silenced things and they come back stronger or is sunlight the best
disinfectant?
Um,
I don't know the answer to that.
I think in general,
I think the American system has,
has worked better,
but I don't know their scholars who could,
who could address that.
Um,
as for what is happening to the left is the left more intolerant.
I,
I agree with you that you would think the left would be more open.
And in my research on left,
right,
the left is generally higher in openness to experience the idea of dissent.
Dissent is patriotic.
These are leftist ideas,
not just idea.
So the left,
it should be more open.
Problem is any group that,
any group that loses a variety that loses diversity,
any group in which everybody thinks the same is at
risk of,
of turning it into an ideology of turned to her religion.
Uh,
and then you lose the ability to think straight.
And now if somebody,
so,
you know,
when I was in college at Yale,
everybody sort of leaned left,
but there was,
they were conservatives,
there were some conservative professors,
like I'd been exposed to some conservative ideas.
But now if you're in a college that has essentially no conservatives that we'll
put out ideas and you encounter one,
now it's much more painful.
It's much more shocking.
Again,
it's like,
it's like you have a peanut allergy to ideas that are not your groups.
And we want,
so we,
it's terrible if we're putting young people in systems that are basically giving
them ideological peanut allergies.
Hmm.
That's a great way to look at it.
Um,
I,
I definitely agree with that in terms of young people,
but I'm,
I'm concerned with grown adults as well.
I think that the way,
uh,
my personal opinion,
the way to con the way to deal with bad speech is better speech or the way the
way deal with shitty ideas is to make those ideas look shitty through debate.
It's not to silence the person that's talking.
This is one of the more confusing things about people that are pulling alarms on
speakers and,
and shouting them down while they're talking.
You have an opportunity when that person's in front of you to listen to their
idea and there should be an opportunity to,
to debate that idea,
to,
to form your own opinion and have a,
a really good argument against it.
And to present that argument and to have people see both sides.
And this is what learning is supposed to be all about,
especially recognizing the flaws and ideas,
recognizing bias,
recognizing the lack of critical thinking or recognizing critical thinking and
applauding it.
Um,
I will agree with you depending on the context.
What I mean is if you have a group of people interacting with certain norms or
laws,
um,
that,
that ban intimidation and violence,
um,
that,
make people,
uh,
have some accountability for how they,
the style that they used to argue.
If you,
if you,
if you lie,
if you threaten something,
you're reputation,
something bad,
we'll come back to you.
Yes.
Meaning intimidation and violence are probably the most,
those are,
um,
and so within a university,
I totally agree with you.
Now,
if you look at the country as a whole or the internet as a whole and you have,
um,
a culture war going on or you have a sense of us versus them and you have all
kinds of bad actors like the Russians discovered,
uh,
you know,
before then that were,
there was the,
the,
you know,
the fake news people who discovered they make fake articles and you know,
on the left and the right and it just turned out that actually the right would
click on the more.
So they went that way.
Um,
there are,
if there are people who are gaming the system,
then your idea,
which is mills' idea,
there are,
I think there are conditions in which it wouldn't work.
I'm not sure about that.
But I think there are six conditions
in which that logic would not work.
And so one thing that I'm very concerned about,
I don't see why it is that we can ever let people start an account where there's
no verification of who they are.
Not saying you can't have anonymous accounts.
Like,
you know,
I understand the reasons why you'd wanna be able to post without your real name.
That's fine.
But if you make a death threat or what,
you know,
what happens a lot is like,
there's research showing if you post something as a woman versus a man,
as a woman,
you're gonna get a lot more rape threats and things like that.
If you,
if you post as a black person or white person,
you get a lot more racist stuff.
So,
um,
at least the platforms should always know that you're a person and that you can,
your account can be shut down if you,
if you talk this way because I think that um,
there are so many people saying such nasty stuff that it feeds back and changes
people's willingness to speak up.
My concern is not necessarily free speech per se,
it's free speech as a means to an end.
And that end is that we as individuals are kind of stupid and we only get smart
if you put us together in the right way where we can challenge each other.
That's what universities should do.
And when we have a call out culture,
we're walking on egg shells,
we can no longer do that.
And in the marketplace of ideas,
I think it's really interesting to see those two things play out.
The one,
the benefit of being anonymous,
that you could talk about things without fear of retribution.
You could talk about things without fear of losing your job and controversial
ideas,
especially in this day and age that you know might not really be that
controversial to you or at least arguable to you,
but that you could get shamed for it and you can get,
people could take your words out of context and you could get in real trouble.
So there's a benefit of an anonymity.
But on the other hand,
when you're looking at slurs,
attacks,
threats,
stalking,
all that stuff,
it would be nice if we knew who was behind all this.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
So that's a case whereby I don't think it's a pendulum.
I do think that there will be some technological solutions and maybe some social
norms so that people who critique in a certain way where it's slurs and it's
guilt by association,
those people will in some sense lose points,
lose credibility,
be downgraded.
My big word for 2019 is nuance that most things are complicated.
Least the things we're talking about are compensated.
And anybody who can say,
you know,
I think you're right about x but wrong about why like that should be a hundred
bonus points.
Yeah.
That is one of the essential skills of,
of sincerely engaging with people.
And anybody who uses guilt by association loses a hundred points.
So like one thing I'm finding because I'm a centrist,
um,
I,
I only vote for Democrats.
I've never voted for a Republican,
but I consider myself philosophically,
um,
to be a centrist and now people will say that I'm all right adjacent.
You know,
like the favorite one,
the adjacency.
That's a,
that's a wonderful,
I get that one because I've had people on the podcast that are right wingers.
Yeah.
So you should say to them or they say on social media is anybody who makes an
adjacency argument.
Um,
is McCarthy adjacent?
That is me.
Say again,
if you're making a guilt
by association argument,
if you,
if you say an adjacency argument,
that's guilt by association.
Anybody does guilt by association is like Mccarthy,
therefore they're McCarthy adjacent.
Yeah.
Wish I said that clear,
but it is a good argument.
That's a good definition of what you're saying.
Um,
it's,
it's a screwy thing that people are doing by this outright adjacent thing.
Well,
you know,
someone wrote a whole chart of like people interacting with people and
connecting these people because they've had communication with these people and
so that somehow or another of these things are all related.
Like,
boy,
that is a,
yeah,
that's a squirrely argument.
No,
but,
but actually this is
the way the human mind works,
right?
We have to see is that we evolved to do this kind of religion with witchcraft
believes and Voodoo.
Yes.
There's all,
you know,
there's all these patterns that recur all around the world and the miracle is
that there have been societies such as ours that developed norms of science,
norms of discourse,
norms of civility,
norms of toleration and free speech where the exceptions and it's precious and
it's easily lost.
I think I fear.
Do you think that it's also this new found ability to communicate that we're
experiencing because of the Internet leads us to a lot of this sort of sloppy
arguing and categories category,
categorizing of,
of humans and ideas that it's this,
we're just not used to these tools yet.
Yes,
but it's not so,
so I,
I put this as a social psychologist.
So most of the commentary about this comes from cognitive psychologists or
people who talk about the information bubbles,
the filter bubbles as though,
you know,
I have my ideas in my head and if I'm exposed only to ideas from here,
then I'm going to have an incorrect bounce of ideas.
So to look at the information flow,
obviously these,
these tools have vastly changed the information flow mostly for the better.
We can Google anything.
At any time.
Um,
so mostly for the better,
but we had this problem of unbounced like,
you know,
you'd only sugar or something so you haven't unbounced.
Dot.
Okay,
fine.
Those are problems.
I'm a social psychologist.
I think the social dynamics problems are vastly bigger,
vastly more dangerous.
And they are that if whatever I say or whether I will agree with you or whether
I'll even press the like button,
I'm thinking,
what's going to happen to me?
Who's going to nail me for it?
And there are people who go through my Twitter feed and they look at what I
liked months or years ago and they'll say,
well,
he liked this or he followed this Brit.
Yeah.
I follow people on the alt right and the far left and communists and fat.
I mean,
yeah,
I study this stuff.
But the idea that you could be somehow,
you know,
blamed for having some connection.
This is what normal human people,
normal human beings do this guilt by association.
And we have to rise above it.
We have to call it out when we see it as it were.
Um,
and realize,
you know what,
we all need critics.
We all need to engage with a variety of viewpoints.
That's what John Stuart Mill said.
That's what common sense will tell you.
Uh,
and if we have institutions that don't expose students to a variety viewpoints,
it's possible that they are making them less wise when they graduate than they
were when they arrived.
Well,
listen,
Jonathan,
we just crank through two hours and a,
I want to thank you for illuminating these ideas and for your great books and,
uh,
and thank you for coming on the podcast anytime you want to do it again.
So now let's do it again.
Thank you.
I'd love thank you so much.
Bye everybody.
Wow.